good morning everyone and welcome to
this meeting of the development control
committee at mid-south district council
um can i first of all just remind us
some of the domestic arrangements for
today can i please ask that your
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking
uh that please we do not interrupt each
other we do that by putting up our hands
if we wish to speak
members are reminded not to use the
messaging or the chat function during
the meeting it is to the sorry message
members are reminded not to use the
messaging and track function during the
meeting unless it is to report a
pecuniary or non-pecuniary interest
or to notify the chair that you wish to
make a proposal
members are reminded that they should
not use have alternative communication
lines open such as teams chat and if you
are contacted by a third party during an
application please bring us to the
attention of the legal advisor
please remember that if you are
attending the meeting to speak and you
do persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair of the
meeting by using the hands up function
and that will we we will be using the
e-voting system for this meeting
if you're experiencing a poor connection
issue the first instance please just try
turning your camera off if this does not
work please then turn off all incoming
video
these options can be found under the
three dots in the main information bar
i'd just like to remind everyone present
this meeting is being broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable for
repeated viewings the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you're making a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded and
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
now i'd like to just do some uh
introductions
uh we have ian de prez who is our legal
advisor good morning ian
robert carmichael who's our governance
offer good morning again robert
we have gemma walker and john payton
g who are the area planning managers uh
good morning to both of you and we have
the case officers present for today
bradley heifer daniel cameron and alex
scott so good morning
during the um
at mid-south district council when there
is an application in the ward of the
member uh the member may speak but may
not vote on that so we have ward members
present today who will be speaking will
be uh sarah mansour john whitehead tim
passman richard mayer
and we have had some written
correspondence as well from councillor
geek
but we'll move on first item on to the
agenda is apologies for absence and
substitutions can i ask the governance
officer for a roll call of members
present please
thank you chair
so we have in attendance all members
apart from councillor uh ebert who has
given our apologies and counselor
stringer is substituting this morning
thank you chair thank you very much uh
gender item number two is to receive
decorations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members
are there any to declare i'd just like
to declare that i am the county council
county councillor for the threadling
division in which one of the uh which is
uh the last application is within my
division
can i make a similar day yes
i'm a county councillor for the uh
gipping valley division and the uh
the development in whitten is in my
division thank you
anyone else wish to declare make any
decorations
nope thank you very much
any declarations of lobbying
to members
um yeah councilman
castle mayor do you just want to come in
and say which one biggie pardon um 7a
yeah i think we've probably all had the
same counts the muller yes seven eight
yeah thank you yeah yes seven a yes yeah
i would imagine everyone has received 7a
if they haven't
uh the only exception might be council
stringer because obviously he's
substituting
pretty sure i have i've received so many
of them it gets difficult to remember
okay thanks very much
um okay agenda item number four is
decorations of personal site visits
uh have anyone got any site uh
declarations site visits to declare
well i've been to the elmsworld site
several times
okay thank you councillor matheson
anyone else
nope okay uh next item is agenda item
number five confirmation uh sorry
councillor mansell uh sorry yeah i am
i i know i'm not voting on the elms or
one but i i have obviously visited the
site that's fine yeah yeah yeah
it's i think it's mainly really for the
voting members
okay
thank you uh next item agenda item five
is confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting that were hailed on the 9th of
december 2020
um are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
no could i therefore have a proposal for
the minutes and a second please
thank you councilman the governance
officer will now conduct an electronic
vote
thank you chair so if members could
please go to the modern.gov app
and go on the plus sign on the agenda in
the top right hand corner
where there will be the attendance and
voting will come up
the vote will appear
shortly
in
light blue color under the point for
minutes i will just start the vote
the vote has now started so it should
appear momentarily in light blue if
members aren't logged in to the
modern.gov app i will take your votes
verbally in just a moment after other
members have voted thank you
thank you so
thank you chair all members have voted
and that is carried unanimously
thank you very much
okay and the minister meeting have been
confirmed and they'll be signed at the
next practical opportunity
agenda item number six is to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
have we had any of those we have
received um
oh i apologize chair
um i think there may have been an error
in that vote last time i've if we could
just very briefly go back i sincerely
apologize um
it appears that councillor passmore and
councillor stringer didn't appear on my
side of the system as not voting on that
point could i please just ask for their
votes on that yeah agreed but i haven't
the voting [ __ ] hasn't come up on my um
my laptop unfortunately
same here i'll struggle to find it but
uh yeah four
could you just ask your story to
interrupt chairman just remind me again
where to find it in case i have made a
mistake but i can't see it's not coming
up double click on the agenda
the blue line will then come across
yeah we've had that yeah and then
at the top of the page
if it's the um plus sign counselor and
that's just that
says attendance voting
yeah the agenda has downloaded with the
blue line but it won't come up on the
screen
is there a plus sign at the end of the
blue bar
at the very end on the right
you click on the plus sign it should
open up there should on the top row
counselor when you open the agenda there
should be a pass
it's just just coming up now so i should
be alright next time sorry about that
thank you um apologies for that chair
and um i will note um if that does
happen again
thank you
okay uh so we're about to receive
notifications and petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme you were just about to say
yep apologies chair so we have received
one valid petition associated with an
application before us today and that is
for application 7a on the agenda and i
will read out the petition statement and
can confirm that 212 valid signatures
have been received with regard in this
application
so we the undersigned petition the
council to retain the mature oak tree
growing in the verge next to school road
elmswell if any road widening scheme
goes ahead
this oak tree has stood in its prominent
position for at least 150 years and is
an impressive and much loved landmark in
the village its age historical
significance and ecological value
mean that it must be saved and should
not fall victim to any road widening
scheme undertaken because of a nearby
housing development
i believe that this will be commented on
by the case officer in their
presentation chair
thank you very much so we note receipt
of the uh petition
uh in accordance with agenda item number
six so thank you very much
okay agenda item uh number seven we move
on to the schedule of the planning
applications um are we uh happy to go
ahead with the agenda item the next item
uh is the parish has the parish council
been contacted
they're now here thank you chair love it
okay so we'll proceed as in uh as in the
papers so the agenda item 7a is dc
1802146
land to the north and west of school
road elmswell and i'll now invite the
case officer john payton g to introduce
the application to the committee john
over to you please
thank you and good morning everybody uh
to bear with me one moment while i
attempt to share
the presentation one one hang on that's
not right
it's just
let me just try that one more time
and
is that seen full screen to everybody
and
everybody can see the presentation
that's fine thank you thank you
unfortunately when you present something
uh you can't actually see anybody else
uh so it's very difficult to work out
what everybody else is seeing thank you
and good morning so uh this is land to
the north and west of school road
elmswell
and it is a outline planning application
for up to 86 uh dwellings and i'll come
back to the proposal as we go through
the presentation
so
this is elmswell
um i think you should be able to see my
cursor elmsworld
and it's uh proposed um just north of
the a14 so we've got elmsworld and we've
got the site in the orange there if you
can see that hopefully
it is a key service center at this time
and we have the aerial map and this
shows the proposal to the west side of
the village
with access to school road which runs
alongside
uh which leads to both the village
center and to the east and out to the
south and connects up to the a4 team
uh it is south of the railway line which
is running across the center of the
slide
and um it's got its own station in as
well
and the railway line itself forms the
northern boundary of the site
i must admit i always mispronounce this
parmell parnell lane
runs runs alongside uh the site
uh in terms of the built form of the
proposed site uh it is a public uh right
of way and it is also
a driveway that leads to elmsworld hall
there is a small tunnel under the um
sorry there's a level crossing and a
pedestrian tunnel uh so the level
crossing for vehicles to go over but
there's a small pedestrian tunnel that
goes under
at this point
of the railway line and you can see in
the green hopefully the other parts of
the public rights away that goes off
into the countryside
the lane itself has an avenue of small
trees that have a useful landmark in the
photos later
and um the east boundary is the back of
gardens to the existing uh development
within the village
while the south boundary beyond is uh
open uh to
other development and the countryside
the site itself is fairly flat
the railway line is elevated as it comes
out of elmsworld it becomes more
elevated in the landscape you can
probably see
the the banking of the land indicated
here
as it goes out and leaves well
we also should point out uh that we have
st john's church which is a great
two-star listed building we also have
the elves houses just next door which
are grade two listed and uh away from
the site but they are important to pick
up because of uh the development that
goes all the way down to the junction uh
for various road works which we'll talk
about later
in terms of the site itself we can
it is adjacent to the current uh
settlement boundary
uh but there is no specific allocations
on the site itself in the current
local plan
in the emerging joint local plan now
record 19 be it of limited weight
it is an allocated site it is la-065
um
and
it you'll also note that the settlement
boundary which is this purple line
has been sought to be extended as part
of the joint local plan as well
this is the indicative master plan for
the proposal
uh it includes a local area
actually a local equipped area of play
uh it also includes land for the early
years
site that's part of the package of
benefits for this development
we have the framework proposal with the
application although not updated in
respect of the
cycle way i'll come back to that later
um
in order to sort of outline sort of the
various zoning of the site
so we're going to we have obviously been
here before in respect of this item
because previously we went away to look
at more details over the junction and
the highways matters raised at the time
but i will go through the photos just
one more time
for the sake of completeness so we start
our photo journey again we have school
avenue to the right and uh existing
properties just past the past bus stop
uh which is just in the picture there
and essentially that is the
corner of the site um that we're looking
at
um
school road is paved uh at least on one
side uh in this case at two at the
moment but as we go along it is paved at
least on one side of the road
from start to finish um
but it isn't the case for the entire
length that is paid for on both sides
so if we just go slightly left we can
see the development on the opposite side
to the site so the site is just
in the in the background and on the
opposite side is uh existing
uh residential development
uh that doesn't go all the way along
there is an open
a patch of land on the corner as we
approach it
so we are on the south is an open
boundary at the moment for the site
and um
we will just carry on looking along this
road this is the southeast corner of the
field
at the moment
and we're coming on walking along
the road
heading towards the corner
and we carry on onwards
so we're now looking roughly where the
new access uh will be
to serve the development and we can see
the backs of the existing end of the
village to the right
and we look again to the existing end of
the backs of the
houses
and we turn around
and we now look at the
small trees that form the avenue
of the lane
and this is the corner of the site the
other corner of the site
um as well and this is in the corner of
the road as it swings around and heads
up towards the church
so various shots of the current open
field
looking again
at the back of those houses again at the
back
of the house as well as you go into the
village
we are getting towards the nearly to the
corner
obviously the drop in levels at this
point is more noticeable
and the trees lead off to where you have
the crossing
to the vowel line and you can see the
railway line as it sort of elevates
itself going off into the distance
and we've now reached the corner
with the footpath to the right
as you can see with the footpath sign so
it goes off that way
and at the corner we drop down probably
to the lowest level
at this point as far as the size is
concerned we're just standing in front
of the site and we're looking up to the
saint john's church in the distance
in the far distance and then we then
start to follow school road so we're
leaving the site at this point now as we
follow the road
so we continue along what is now perhaps
a more narrow path uh not wide enough
for two people to uh pass
um the road is just about wide enough
for passing traffic but i will admit
that twice in my visit
i've got a van and a car decided to
mount the path when faced with a larger
vehicle
coming the opposite direction
we can also pause at this point just to
look at this oak tree on the right-hand
side now this has been the subject of a
position that was mentioned at the
beginning
uh since the last committee and um i
believe it's actually possibly been in
the uh newspaper as well
um now i'm going to be honest here i
admit i thought this was a loss to the
scheme previously but i have been proven
wrong
and generally very glad to be proven
wrong and i would say
perhaps unusually i believe this
sentiment to be shared
very solidly by the applicant and their
representatives this tree will now be
protected
not just by a piece of paper which is in
progress at the moment for a tree
preservation order
but also because we have changed the
scheme to ensure that the development
for the cycle route will go around it
um and we'll come back to that in a
little while
so the existing path as you see here
will be diverted
and removed
the tr
the road itself will physically be
widened very slightly
but it will not affect the tree as the
infrastructure is already effectively
there
the
any remaining part of the path
will be
reverted back into soft verge
um
and um you know to achieve the the 5.5
meters needed
obviously there's a little verge on the
other side as well so there's there's
plenty of room to do that
and the remaining any remaining path
will be converted back into the soft
urge
and serve the tree i will come back to
that
with the plans in a little while but
we'll continue our journey on the photos
for the moment
so when these pictures were taken it was
ten past nine in the morning and we have
traveled almost to the end
of school road where we reach uh church
road
uh the church is on the far right we
have this church and we have the list of
elms houses uh just there as well
just turning around at that point we see
the
line of trees that is the avenue of the
lane
and um yeah just past the 30 mile now
sign
the whole road is 30 miles an hour
um
and a significant landscape buffer is
part of the considerations around uh the
size of that end
just to put into context as you're
looking around in various angles
and finally we're at the junction
so just to put the junction into context
this is essentially in my view the
entrance to the village from the a14 as
you come up the hill
and you enjoy the setting of the church
and the arms houses before faced with a
choice of ways uh through elmsworth so
you've got the arms houses just on the
right there as you're coming into the
village you'll be on the left
and you're faced with choice um of
direction at this point as you can see
by the signs now the signs are all
trying to encourage everybody to go
through
the school road
especially in terms of
industrial traffic
now
this proposal includes improvements to
this junction and
to realign and widen it and it is
considered to be needed for good reason
perhaps fairly well demonstrated by this
picture
this is a typical problem
for the junction both a safety issue
and a delay because ultimately cars or
other vehicles have to wait for this
situation to resolve itself
and so i have some other examples of
speeches sorry of the junction just to
get you an
overarching view of
that kind of issue at the moment
and then we jump right back to the
beginning the site is now back to the
left-hand side
and this time we shall very quickly just
travel from the site into the village
so as we go into the village itself
obviously this is more built up
on
on school road we have a fire rescue
service with police
which i think are on the left in this
picture
we have
fish and chips hairdressers a chinese
takeaway
and various properties of various ages
and styles
we also have a wesley chapel
which will be a community hub
this picture was taken a little while
ago so i'm sure works have moved on from
from this point
we have a pub next door to that
all within a very short distance of the
site itself
and then the remaining road that leads
to the junction
and to the left of that is the railway
crossing and then the station
and also other shops
so a lot of photos thank you for bearing
with me as we got through those
um
but i think walking the entire route is
important to understand the location of
the site and some of the issues
as well
let's jump back to the junction
for the moment this will include
realignment widening a possession
crossing point from widened paths and a
shared path for cycle and footpath
use
no traffic lights
this is not part of the proposal um we
have reevaluated this we have gone back
and our a member from the highways
authority uh from the county council is
also with us today as well to help
answer any questions
we are not seeking traffic lights as
part of this proposal and is not secure
not sought to be secured either
the proposal before us is what is needed
for the burden of this particular
development bearing in mind other
developments within the area
and it increases the safety of the
junction for everybody as well
so this is the this is the proposal
there is no future proposal this is the
proposal
that is being presented to members
while we have a cycleway
from the development secured which is a
significant length of infrastructure we
also have an option
which
will be for
future consideration but land option for
going around the church to further
extend that cycle way as well um which
is
good because i think it is a clear
linkage to eventually get to warped
that the county would like to see the
current um revision of the joint local
plan has picked this up and it is also a
local ambition i believe
just a close-up to the junction works
this is the same slide as before just a
bit closer
you can see the points of the pedestrian
crossing
the path to the right is realigned
so it's increased out
so essentially pedestrians can see
around the corner further without
stepping onto the road compared to the
current situation
the um the dark
um
line is the new alignment the gray line
is the
current alignment so it just sort of
steps out a little bit further to allow
you to get a little bit more vision as
you're looking around that corner
the opposite side is obviously there's
less curvature to concern yourself there
but again i've been realigned
as well
now in order to try and explain this a
bit more i've attempted
to do a bit of colouring in um
and i'm not sure if it's any better or
worse than my children at the moment but
in terms of helpfulness i hope this
helps a bit further for members to
understand the proposal
so
what we've done here is that in pink is
essentially the existing
road that's there at the moment and the
arrangement at the moment uh the sky
blue
section is essentially the extended road
area
and the gray on both sides so the grey
here and the grey here
is the
footpath or combined footpath and
cycleway
back to
the site itself which is just to the
north here
since the last committee this plan has
changed and you will see the cycle route
and path are now re-routed
to goo and steer if we get the pun past
the uh
valued oak tree
so this is a close-up of the same slide
again
um and i'm now wishing to be fair that i
would also color this in pink and blue
um but please bear with me um the thick
black line which are these lines here
as you can see is the proposal
in respect of
the the poe's new road and widening
the gray lines are the existing
features of the road and road alignment
so the road
the widening of the road along the road
is not going to be uniform it does have
to respect the tree and work to control
speed
um which i hope is demonstrated here
the
um obviously in terms of the corner
you'll see the widening is a lot more um
you know we're going out further
but to be fair in my opinion there's
almost another lane as you're coming
around that corner
in order to resolve what is a tight
corner um on this corner i'll be honest
i've obviously been working in
mid-suffolk for a very long time i've
gone to elmswell many many many times
in my experience when you currently turn
this bend and there is a vehicle hgv
coming in the other way you do breathe
in and hope the car is doing the same
your officers
also on this occasion have recommended a
condition on the finer details of the
widening and improvements
uh across the entire uh scheme
in terms of the road widening and the
junction to be agreed with the local
planning authority and not just with the
highways authority
we feel is reasonable to ensure a high
quality piece of infrastructure is
secured
and our commitment to the elements such
as the tree
to be secured and continued
this is a proposal for 86 dwellings
um it's around 19.1 dwellings per
hectare
it was for a larger number but during
the course of the application the number
was reduced and more infrastructure
elements increased
unusually the applicant has also agreed
the tenure of the housing as part of
this outline
and this is to ensure it accords with
the housing needs that your housing
officers have identified
so
meaning this is fixed and a clear
benefit for housing need to be secured
at this stage
this is outlined but it does include the
access um and it also includes a range
of the highways improvements that we've
talked about
in terms of the access it is considered
acceptable and supported by the highways
authority
we do have submissions received
objecting to the scheme on traffic
grounds
in particular the capacity of the
existing road network to absorb the
traffic generated by this development
many are critical of the capacity of
school lane given it's never whipped but
in part this is proposed to be widened
as a benefit of this scheme
which is something that no other scheme
is proposing
and is sought to be secured um i hope
the photos have demonstrated this point
and clear need for the works offered
this would secure mitigation against the
burden of this development but i think
also very much the wider public benefit
for other developments ongoing and
coming forward in elswell
the development goes on to provide a
significant length of cycleway link for
the intended elm as well and wall pit
link
we secured an option of extending this
further around the church
uh and
this option hopefully uh would allow
uh the
point being that you get to this point
and you may be faced with this road but
we have the option to further this we
get around to perhaps a safer point
for then further
contributions or works to take the link
further and off into the wall pit
direction
the um obviously there will be future
contribution needed to complete that
link
from other schemes or other sources
in terms of landscape and trees well our
position has improved in terms of one
tree since the last committee
but the application in all other
respects was considered acceptable and
this development in the corner is
considered to be accommodated
and suitable landscaping possible which
would be effective
around uh on the edge of this settlement
as a whole
and we have that demonstrated in the
parameters plan
the detailing of the actual landscaping
itself what type of trees and so on
is a reserved matter still and that is
deemed to be suitable to deal with at
that time
um the site itself
is already enclosed by an aviator of
trees bit small trees on on the lane but
also enclosed by the railway line and
existing development there is a good
sense of containment and the indicative
plan demonstrates this can be increased
further avoid spilling out into the open
landscape
and avoids intrusion of the
indivisibility between the church across
the valley
and elmsworth hall just beyond
this leads nicely to heritage i'm going
to repeat this again
in terms of the report
the council's heritage officer has
reviewed
all information and the supporting
heritage statement and the changes in
the proposal over time
and they accept that the present
proposal reduces harm considerably by
limiting the proposal to the
east of the lane
in the corner of this area but there
will be a degree of harm be it low
and
any development of this sword will have
a less than substantial harm
element especially in terms of the
setting in this case on elsewhere hall
be it on the other side of the railway
line
the
historic england has been concerned with
the impact of the proposal on the open
landscape setting initially because this
development was far larger and went out
into the countryside far more
but now are content to rely on the
heritage team's advice
and the officer
report does consider
this importance that we have considered
the importance of the harm identified
but ultimately we have balanced that
with the significant public benefits and
we feel they very much outweigh the harm
identified
other matters
for example
flood and water management they do not
object to the scheme subject to
conditions and there's no reason to
hold consent on flood or drainage
grounds at this time
so lastly
to conclude
in conclusions we consider there is a
significant package of public benefits
86 dwellings including parking and open
space 35 affordable housing a set mix of
housing for both affordable and market
housing to meet your housing team
offices requirements for this area
site for early years provision
we have a contribution if that can't be
taken up but it is provided with this
site a new school contribution
extension extensive road widening for
school road and the church road
junction as well
we have significant division of cycle
footwear
a long school road and the junction
and an optional route to continue that
around the church itself
and therefore our recommendation for you
today
is to approve and set out in your papers
many thanks
very much for that uh
okay so uh do we have any questions from
members on what's been presented to us
uh first of all councillor muller
thank you chair um yes this may be more
of a question for the arbor cultural
officer
um with regards to the cycleway proposed
to go around the tree
can you please confirm that no damage
will be done to the root system of the
oak tree thank you
um we don't we did ask if he would be
able to attend today but i'm i'm not
sure if uh david our officer free
officer was able to attend today i'm
assuming he's not out there i can't see
on this computer i'm afraid um but the
answers to that is that um the
the the route um
let me start actually from the beginning
let me go to the right drawing there we
go that was good timing um so in terms
of the the routing
what we found since last committee is
strut strands have actually
reserved or purchased land that goes out
quite wide in order to ensure that the
routing because they recognized many
many years ago the routing of this
cycle way would need to avoid the tree
now i'll be honest with you we didn't
realize that until we had to investigate
it further since last committee so um
we're quite pleased we did
so this route uh is far enough out
beyond uh it should be beyond the roots
now
when you tend to look at the roots you
tend to look at the drip line and then
add a bit more uh to the tree itself
we will probably this the finer detail
of this
we have put as a condition uh in your
papers to ensure that if we need to move
this out very a little bit more to
ensure the roots are definitely not
affected that is what we will do
we've also got a tree preservation order
that would be
in place before any decision is issued
to ensure that as well so
uh we are comfortable that that is
workable without affecting the roots
thank you thank you councillor matheson
thank you yeah very very um very similar
um concerned councillor muller there
that was that the the road would be
widened beside the tree
um
and i think we'll probably need to
kind of come back in the conditions or
something at the end
um
that the
that we we must not be in widening the
road we must not be actually deepening
into into the roots
um any closer to the tree than the road
already is that that's really debate for
the for the for what's the question for
the officer
yeah so i mean i i just you know i'm
just highlighting that that that
particular point was made i think the
other
we do have luke barber here from uh
county highways he may be able to uh
qualify this better than i can but
ultimately the um
the the built highway is the path
already there
so you can see that the stripper path
and you can see the the road but in
terms of their built foundation they're
all part of the same structure
the widening of the road
essentially takes the path out slightly
but it doesn't actually mean that it
needs to
go any further to affect the roots
beyond what is already affected at that
point
and i don't think it's all of the path
anyway it's about halfway um yeah there
is a finer detail to this which is
conditioned in your papers um and we you
know and
in all respects
that we we need to go and not affect the
roots any more than they're already
affected by the the arrangement in place
uh that that is the point
so we're perhaps hearing that the the um
the foundations of the road
are are the same foundations already
underneath the footwear you think that's
what i believe but ultimately the the
widening of this part of the road is not
as wide as other parts of the the whole
road that are proposed they are it is
not going to be uniformed so it's not
trying to achieve
a
continuous uh width all the way along
because we need to be respectful of the
various items along the road and that
includes the tree this time and i'll be
honest with you last time around we
didn't we thought in a way the tree was
gonna be sacrificed this time around we
are very clear on what is the
intention and requirements of the
council and we will be looking to
preserve that
yeah the the other the other question at
that end of the scheme
the um the option to to um to take these
the cycle route
around the church
are you able to confirm whether that
will marry up with the the other
sustrans um owned land
which i believe was purchased down the
hill to the roundabout
um
one moment let me yeah
so
the the stops the strat strands route
was based on the intention that you
would end up somehow going across in
front of the church
and then going following down here uh on
other on other owned land
um obviously that they've taken that out
in terms of reserving that land
um what we've suggested is that yes
that's possible and that is what is
proposed to you today and we will
achieve it to this point
but there is but it kind of lets you
just go straight out into the main road
as cars are coming out up the hill and
it might be
a consideration later where we have
reserved the land that goes around the
church which effectively deposits you
out onto a quieter lane
as a cyclist
um especially if you you know cycling
with family and so on um that allows you
then to go up to the link and back down
that piece rather than taking
yourselves out onto this perhaps more
busier road yeah yeah um so that is the
reason we we thought it would be a
really good idea to secure a route
around the church as much as comply with
the route that everybody had initially
uh
put put forward does that does that help
yeah yeah that that does help so that
you're confident that the
the land the land that's potentially
offered and can be secured goes right
around the church to reach the that is
the agreement
so the owner of the site here owns all
of the field um so we have that as part
of the agreement that is uh
in your papers for the recommendation
good
councilor mayor
thanks chip um mr gene could you um just
bring up the slide showing the
pedestrian crossing please
um
do you mean that one that one
i look at that position and can you
assure us that a pedestrian crossing
running across
the entrance there is indeed safe is it
going to be um light controlled my
concern being
as you come up the hill from the left
you won't see a red light until you turn
up and then by then it's going to be too
late
if there was no there was no intention
to put lights in so it's not going to be
like controlled they are pedestrian um
crossing points but it is that is it
that's not there no lights intended so
so tactile paving
that that position
adheres to current legislation safety
advice because it seems very close to
that junction to me let's bring in luke
barber who's with us uh from the
highways department luke could you
comment on that please
uh yes so yeah thank you councillors um
yeah the the final design of this
junction will um be secured through a
section 278 agreement and that will
require
all stages of road safety audits so both
the design
uh will be safety audited
and prior to uh opening to the public it
will be safety ordered then it would be
safety audited after a period to sort of
check the operation of the junction i
think my my reading of the drawing is
this is maybe and i
maybe
this does look to me like it does have
some of the characteristics of the
signal scheme in that it's showing um
stop lines instead of give way lines so
i think while the curb lines are correct
the um
some of the finer points yes um i think
i think i think this this drawing that
john is now showing is is more correct
in that it has the uh the give way line
junction that um
so yes the crossing points would be just
back from the giveaway lines but they
would have to be selected by the
designers to have the best um
best pedestrian visibility and the
widening the curbline widening does
allow for those um crossing points to be
put in in the best possible place where
you've got sort of into visibility
between the motor vehicles and the
pedestrian
did you want to come back counselor
mayor at all
no not at this time i think it's more
for discussion thank you thank you a
councillor stringer
uh
thank you chair two questions uh could i
could the officer please confirm
that the
junction improvement to school road
church road
would not improve capacity for the
school road arm and queuing would remain
and the second question is are there
other sites
in this in this location and served by
this road network in this location in
the proposed joint local plan
thank you
so i didn't quite catch the last
question because my microphone came out
something like a joint local planner
the last question was are there other
sites
served by school road church road
that are proposed in the joint local
plan
so
let me answer that one first because i
think i put the
there we go
so the other site
uh allocating it calculated is
la-064
which is that there does that help
counselor answer that uh it does i take
it does that does or does not have
planning permission
not at this stage there's no planning
application for that one that's very
helpful thank you um but it is taken
into account in respect to the transport
surveys and strategy that we have got
because obviously it's one of the
allocations that uh has been taken into
account with that information so that's
you know the potential of that
is considered um with regard to the
transport assessment made
um
in terms of the capacity of the junction
um i'm going to have to ask luke if he
can possibly help me further in terms of
the car i said i think it changes the
capacity of the junction it improves its
efficiency uh on the basis obviously you
know the point of the fact that you have
lorries uh coming along to the junction
and effectively stopping everything
working while they get through it
whereas obviously in the renewal
alignment they'll have enough space to
be able to maneuver and other cars and
other vehicles get around them at the
same time so in terms of efficiency i
would suggest and safety they would be
it would be improved capacity i'm not
aware that there would be a change luke
is that
is the position it will it will improve
its capacity um to uh
to an extent i mean it's it's still a
the same formal junction in that it's a
priority junction would give way but
because there is localized widening it
does allow for more cars to um
to stack um
at the uh
so it does
it does provide some
capacity benefit but but i would i
wouldn't overstate that because it's uh
um you know not not going to be a
dramatic improvement in capacity that
you would get from you know changing the
form of the junction but but it is still
a net gain in its capacity but as you
say it's arising from greater efficiency
sorry if i can just come back on that
because it's quite critical page 27
in the highways response
it clearly states it would not improve
the capacity of the school road arm so
you're now saying it will improve the
capacity
i think what we're saying is improve the
efficiency that is the clear gain here
in respect of how the junction works
that there's a very minor gain in
capacity on that basis but no i think
you know if we were looking for a clear
statement i think we would be safer to
say no in a realistic sense i'm sorry
luke barber just said capacity would be
improved sorry
when you when you increase the
efficiency of a working junction i think
there is obviously some gains here
because you're going to have a wider
road
which allows more cars to kind of go
against each other but ultimately it's
quite marginal so i'm i i think you have
to accept that is the position we have
in front of us
okay thank you councillor
uh thank you chair for allowing me a
question i just really would like some
some confirmation from the officer that
in our paper pack on page 247 we have a
slide nine showing a mini roundabout and
i just like to confirm that
that the officer to confirm that that is
irrelevant and we should be ignoring it
yes i'm not quite sure why it's there
the paper pack yes my apologies for that
the paperback hasn't been updated
it's difficult because when we have to
defer one committee to the next you
can't
change as many things in terms of the
bundle um the please ignore the
roundabout it was a idea that was
explored because we were trying to find
every alternative there could be to
other ideas to
make a difference uh and improve this
locality unfortunately a roundabout was
not deemed to be a viable option or
possible so please ignore that
what has been presented before us today
is is really what we're considering is
purely what
uh thanks matthew i'd just like to ask
john um regarding the landscaping on the
western fringe i understand it's
obviously put in a reserved matter but
how as a planning authority if this were
to go ahead would we ensure that it
really is a an excellent landscaping
scheme i'm not suggesting the applicant
wouldn't want to do that because what
i've heard i think they probably would
do but
what i'm really looking for here because
it is quite a prominent site if it goes
ahead that landscaping on that western
fringe
really would cut the mustard and be
something that we could all be very
pleased and proud of and um have all the
relative advantages because in the past
in some areas going back a few years uh
one has to question whether the
landscaping has been a put in and looked
after and done properly how how could
that be conditioned
we've got to be careful not to veer into
debates just no no no no i'm asking you
a question matthew that's all how would
it how would you do it what would you
what would you suggest that's all i want
to know thank you
the ultimate position here is that
landscaping is a reserve matter but i
think what we have to be looking at in
terms of the principle of development is
the clear opportunity that landscaping
is possible and you know quite often we
look at housing estates and you kind of
go well they've got very small gardens
but landscaping will solve it but
actually the opportunity is the garden
is so small that you can't put decent
trees in you can't put decent planting
in of any real whip to to mitigate the
harm
in this case um and i put it on this
plan purposely you know we have a clear
understanding uh given to us in terms of
the the successful placement of the
built form
and the containment of that
versus where the real landscaping and
it's on the other side of the road it
needs to take place there's no pressure
to put housing on the other side of the
road because we wouldn't approve that
for heritage reasons if nothing else
so we have a lot of area here to ensure
uh quite a significant opportunity for
landscaping can can occur
that said further down here there is a
need for openness to be maintained
because that is part of the
characteristic of traveling along this
road and looking out across the valley
which dives away
landscaping is a reserve matter and
obviously because it'll be part of a
significant scheme such as this it will
come back to members as well
and ultimately members will be the
judges of whether the landscaping and
its significance is sufficient in this
case
thank you very much john just what i
wanted thank you thank you councillor
field
[Music]
thank you chair
it's difficult to ask questions always
that improve clarity rather than getting
us deeper into the mirror of
misunderstanding
and cancer stringer covered much of this
but just one more go
the development of the junction by the
church
you're saying
in some way widening the road
a little
either increases or doesn't increase
capacity according to which bit of
papers we read and who's speaking
but what i wanted to establish is the
clear understanding that the 18 car
q lengths that you're generating the
exceeding capacity in the peak hour
has been simulated if we implement more
elements of our local plan
but not for this element of the local
plan
so what are the queue lengths what how
what does the junction capacity how do
the q links vary
with the proposals of this
particular development you know
trying to ignore the confusion thrown in
by all the other elements can we have
some clarity on that please
can i i'm going to have to stop
presenting and go back
because obviously i can't unfortunately
because of the arrangement i've got here
i can't work and
present at the same time to bear with me
please
so
if i
should have that at the top there
kids
i'm i'm just reviewing the live stream
and it appears to have a bit of a
buffering issue so if i could just ask
for a very quick break just to try and
sort that out to restart our streaming
software which will hopefully resolve
the issue because it's currently stuck
on a picture um from a few moments ago
we're still going out but um
start again at 10 40 to give everyone
just to grab a quick cuppa
if we're going to take a break and then
we'll keep we'll have another hour and a
half two hours following that break so
it will start again at 10 40.
um it's now 20 to 11. we'll kick off
again uh with the meeting uh just ask
robert carmichael just to do real cool
just to make sure everyone is back
please thank you chair
so councillor john field
yes
councillor hicks
yeah councilman mansell
i i think i heard council man
she was here yeah yep councillor
matherson yes councillor mayor yup
that's la muller present
council
yes
and
right thank you very much now we were
just into a question i think council
stringer had you finished your questions
you were sorry you'd asked a question
and john paint mcgee was about to
respond that's correct said john over to
yes so in terms of the first question um
in terms of um the
car lengths um i've got
here uh just going through the traffic
um so the transport assessment um
obviously there's there's flows of
traffic and there's there's the queuing
and the queueing side of things is that
in terms of the am peak period
the sort of the worst case scenario is
18 car limps
could be queuing at this junction as you
approach it from school road to
church road
that's in the a.m peak and in the pm
peak it is nine
um so far less than 18. but that is for
the
development and the accumulative
development in the locality
so the guess would be that obviously for
just this development if it was looked
upon itself only that number would be
far less but i don't have what that
model data would be if you just looked
at this development on its own
ultimately
maybe the agent might have that to hand
but
i don't have that here that i can
quickly lay my hands on so what we've
got is the worst case scenario uh the
with the development and the
accumulative development uh within
elmswell
and so this was the maximum
model is showing is 18
car lengths in the am peak period that
could be queuing at this junction that's
all i have
and of course that's expressed in the
highways authorities response
as well um uh picking up on
sort of the the
the the worst case scenario that's here
um in respect of this but of course none
of that is regarded as severe in respect
of our considerations of the mppf and
our considerations of highways
thank you did you want to come back
council australia
oh sorry i'm my apologist cassie
the concern is that we
the we have some evidence of
a queue length of 18 that's a heart
a number of schemes and we have lots of
um
assurances that don't have any evidence
behind them so that's all i really
really wish to establish thank you sorry
thank you uh
councilman
thanks chair um the
question of severe impact has been
mentioned several times
but i couldn't find any mppf a
definition of what that severe is do we
have a definition or is it just
highway's opinion that it is not severe
jonathan maybe luke would you like to
comment please
there is a judgment to be made there
ultimately
but it is not um
the advice we have from highways is it's
not severe to warrant refusal uh but i
could leave it to luke if he wishes to
add more to that
uh thank you councillors yeah this is
probably the singularly most
um challenging part of the the role of
the highway authority that the mppf
although setting out the severe test
doesn't quantify the the severe test
over the years the the previous severe
test in the
original uh draft bmpf as a sort of
revised in 2019 has been tested several
times an appeal
in suffolk we generally fought and and
the severe test now has two what we call
two limbs it has a capacity limb
and a road safety limb uh we generally
find in in suffolk that it would be very
difficult to evidence the capacity limb
almost anywhere outside of the largest
towns
i mean there have been appeal decisions
across the the country in large built-up
areas that look at sort of
you know
well um capacity being so degraded that
an additional 15 minutes of delay per
junction could be considered severe now
there's literally nowhere in suffolk
where that
um such a such a high bar would be
breached
so we tend to focus on the road safety
limb of this severe test so in some
cases ex um poor performance of
junctions can give rise to safety
concerns if a
cue was to
um
you know exceed the length that somebody
you know could could predict it can't
you know potentially come around a a
bend and be confronted by
um stationary vehicles you know securing
for a roundabout for example or if the
if the queue length exceeded
the slip road length on a high-speed
road such as the a14 um you know we'd be
very concerned about that and highways
england would be very concerned about
that because you potentially have
stationary vehicles backing up into 70
mile an hour uh sort of free-flowing
vehicles on the strategic road network
so it is a very is very difficult it is
very subjective um and but it is really
born out through
careful
consideration of appeal decisions that
take that have taken place in suffolk
but also also wider in other locations
in in the uk but yes very challenging
thank you very much does that answer
your question councilman yeah i think it
justifies their case i'm not sure
answers um
my quest for a definition of severe
thank you did you want to come in uh
into praise our legal adviser on that
well yes just just briefly if i may just
i think as a quick matter of law
councillor mayor is quite right
there isn't like a glossary definition
in the nppf of um
of severe impact and that that's been
commented on in lots of places or not
just in our area but yeah as a matter of
law the mppf is policy that's a material
consideration the courts have said a
number of times when you're looking at a
policy it's not the same as a act of
parliament or a business contract you
give it a broad
um
common sense
interpretation having read the whole
document in context but yes i think i
have to endorse what luke says that i
think members would be expected in doing
that to have regards to professional
advice which is what he's just given you
and to
how planning inspectors have
have interpreted and lucas indeed helps
you with that so i just yeah i i i
thought it would just be helpful for me
to add that
thank you very much uh councilman
thank you chair yeah i i wanted to make
sure um members were not um this is a by
way of a correction in the report really
um
page 26
the historic england
um
point summarized there
i think mr payment g correctly said
um what the situation was but the
do not wish to offer any on offer any
comments what they actually said on page
55 was they did not wish to offer any
further comments i think that is
significantly different but that mr
payment g did i i think set out what
page 55 says
uh in reality but just just a little
concern there thank you
do you want to comment
john paymentry do you want to comment
no
no i don't think i need to comment uh in
in terms of the document obviously if
members look at page 55 um
ultimately
on the basis of the result
revised information we do not wish to
offer any further comments essentially
because the scheme was reduced
from 105 to
86 and because the locality
of the built form was significantly
changed to go into the corner if you
like rather than spill out as far as it
did previously
uh they've kind of pulled back that's
probably the best way i can describe it
to um sort of push it back down to our
local heritage officers to
make that call and of course we
obviously went back to them and
and they have provided the comments that
they've provided i i think that
obviously members are welcome to please
look at the full text in page 55
and take it from there thank you very
much thank you terry we're going to move
on we have no other hands up so we'll
move on now um to public speakers um so
i'd now like to ask the parish council
to speak uh mr peter dao if you'd like
to turn your camera and your microphone
on please from the parish council
thank you chairman can you hear me
yes we can and over to you and you have
three minutes
a quick roll call just to make sure
everyone's present over to please
robert carmichael
here
present
yes
here
present
present
present
thanks very much
okay so um we just had uh the uh three
minutes from the parish council um no
hands actually had gone up at the end of
that but just to double check before we
move on were there any questions that
anyone thought of they'd like to ask the
parish council yep we have some hands
that have gone up now okay so first of
all we'll go to councillor muller then
councilman matheson thank you chair uh
mr dale you mentioned in your three
minutes about the number of large hdv
lorries using the junction at church
road and school road can you please
confirm whether that's mainly during the
rush hours in the morning in the
afternoon or are there large numbers of
these large vehicles using that road
throughout the day thank you
i would suggest that it is fairly evenly
based throughout the day if there is a
peak it is coming back in at around
between five o'clock and six o'clock
which unfortunately coincides with
uh the general commuter traffic
thank you mr dave thank you
thank you uh councilman
i think this one will be a question for
mr g arising from what mr dao has said
the um
the the extra um was it 80 or 90 or
something um beyond the bacon factory
site that that's that were approved a
few months ago
i think these were not within the joint
local plan proposed allocations
and if they were not
were they
or were they not taken into the traffic
assessments that we've been discussing a
few minutes ago
my understanding is the traffic
assessment takes into account all the
current applications and that
application was ongoing for some time
as well as the allocations but
um
i can't be an absolute certain that it
included that or not it might be a
question for the applicant perhaps i
would suggest just to make sure i'm i'm
right there but my understanding when i
looked at the premise of it was that it
should have included all of the ongoing
applications
as well as in order to do the
accumulative modeling it has to include
all the applications that within the
area as well as the allocations uh that
were proposed at the time so um i think
for confirmation it might be uh
prevalent to ask the applicant i don't
know if luke knows more than i do but i
think that's probably the best idea
okay luke did you want to comment or
we'll take it we'll take we'll follow
that
ask that question for the applicant
yeah i must confess i don't i wasn't i
didn't deal with this aspect of the
application but what john has said in
terms of general principle of committed
developments isn't entirely correct
thank you okay any other questions
thanks john any other questions the
parish council
okay thank you very much uh thank you
for joining us today uh next up we'll
move to the agent james bailey uh who
wishes to speak we have victoria barbara
to answer questions
mr bailey you have three minutes
excellent just starting off sir can you
can you see me uh okay
yep that's fine and you can hear me as
well yeah
fantastic
good morning chair uh members here we
are again to discuss the sights at
school rhode island as well and it is
unfortunate that this virtual uh meeting
environment seems to be with us for a
little while longer
since the 11th of november the applicant
landowner and their consultant team have
worked exceedingly hard to continue to
engage positively with officers members
and also local residents i shall now
outline the positive improvements that
have been made starting with the
highways and we also have our highways
consultant on hand to answer any
specific questions that you may have
it is now hoped that the improvements to
the church road and school road junction
have been made clear following any
concerns at the last committee the
junction improvements notably the
widening at the entrance should be seen
as a positive for both flows of traffic
and it is hoped that the plans
photographs and visualizations all help
to illustrate this
it has also been clearly confirmed that
traffic signals are not required as part
of this application nor will they be
required for the growth anticipated in
the joint local plan
following on from this we can also
confirm that the full length of school
road from the church road junction to
the proposed site entrance will no
longer be widened in its entirety
instead it will only be widened at
certain key places which has been
discussed and agreed with both highways
officers and your own planning officers
this should help to slow traffic along
school road as members pointed out at
the last committee
i am sure that you will recall there has
been significant concerns raised
regarding the retention and the
protection of the oak tree off school
road
the applicant and especially the
landowner have embraced these comments
and have actively sought ways to achieve
keeping this tree a tpo has been
actively encouraged discussions with
action groups and concerned residents
have taken place and members have been
kept informed along the way
we now have a scheme before you today
that not only retains this important
tree but has also carefully considered
it within the proposals there also
remains the opportunity for further
landscaping at certain points as has
been raised this morning
since the november committee the
emerging joint local plan has moved a
step closer towards adoption and the
application site of school road
continues to feature as an allocation
identified as
la065 therefore there remains a reliance
and an expectation on this site being
brought forward and delivering houses at
some point in the future
all of these changes have been discussed
and agreed with the district and county
offices since we met last november this
is on top of the other benefits that are
being offered offered by this scheme
which should not be forgotten
an agreed housing mix including
affordable homes and bungalows increased
landscaping and open space throughout
the proposal the provision of land for a
preschool plus a significant delivery of
the important part of the wool pitting
elmsworld footpath and cycleway i
therefore respectfully request that
members endorse their office's
recommendation and approve this
application this morning thank you
indeed very much for your time but
please let us know if you should have
any specific highways related questions
as there may be
thank you very much
okay happy opening up to members
counselor mayor first and cancer maths
thank you mr bailey um probably one for
your highways consultant do you believe
that the current position shown for the
pedestrian cost crossing at the bottom
of school road is safe
if i can chair uh can i bring in uh
victoria balboa from from pell freshman
she's been looking at this site for a
number of years since before back in uh
the application was put in in 2018 so
she will know this particularly well if
i can call on on on victoria now that
that would be very helpful
yep please if you'd like to turn your
camera on and answer the questions being
asked thank you good morning
um
the the exact location of the crossing i
think is the best location we can get if
you look at where the crossing is at the
moment where the pedestrian cross
crossing at the moment is on that
junction it is quite close to the stop
line because we're widening the footway
there we're able to push it slightly
further back and once the detailed
design is done it may be that we can
push it further further northwards a
little bit more but certainly it's an
improvement on the existing situation
and in the best location we can get it
my question was do you believe the
crossing's safe
well i'm good there's no history of
pedestrian accidents at that junction so
i'm i i've got no reason to think that
it wouldn't be safe
what
it's better than what it's better than
what you have at the moment what speed
can car cars take that junction coming
up the hill from the roundabout from
wall pit you can do 30 miles an hour
because it's not a right angle turn you
can take that junction at 30 miles an
hour
is that is that pedestrian crossing site
okay so in that in that situation yes so
in the um
when you have the the crossing on the
left hand side of the drawing as you're
looking at it
so on the west side you've got full
visibility around that movement
on the east side of the crossing that's
where you're very slightly restricted
for vehicles that are coming from the
north but they of course are are slowing
down to stop at that point
so there's no there's no reason for
those vehicles to be traveling or they
wouldn't be able to travel at fast speed
coming around the corner
which is the where the pedestrian
visibility is very slightly limited
okay thank you thank you councilman
thank you the yes coming to the question
that i
i asked mr dao a moment or two ago um
can we can we be assured that the
transport assessment that we're now
looking at
um or the consequences
in it in the report um
take into consideration the extra i
think it was 80 something
houses that were
allowed
and i think it was confirmed outside the
allocations proposed in the emerging
joint local plan
yeah so i've i've pulled up the um the
committee report for the bacon factory
this additional the 65 dwellings
from last year
and
it helpfully contains a summary of their
assessment of that junction
and they have reported exactly the same
results that we have reported they've
reported the rfc being 1.05 with a key
length of 18
and that that assessment was done
last year so
and would and would of course have
included their own development traffic
so
on that basis yes our junction results
are the same as theirs
all right thank you
thank you cancer field
thank you there's been debate about
capacity at the junction and statements
that the increased road width
improves the capacity
i have some difficulty to see how
our queue gets any shorter because the
roads a couple of foot wider could you
just explain how how that capacity
improves
occurs
um
so i'll do my best to i'll do my best to
explain um in the way that luke and john
have also explained it
when looking at junction capacity there
are a number of geometrical parameters
that are taken into account so when the
theoretical capacity is assessed the
width of the road is a factor
but there's a certain point where the
width of the road no longer benefits um
capacity
and so when luke said there would be
some marginal capacity improvements
because we were riding the road he was
correct
however in this instance because we're
widening
to allow hdvs to pass rather than
specifically for cars
the capacity benefits
are not significant they're not
realistically significant
and so we haven't um we haven't adjusted
our models to take into account we're
not claiming there's any additional
capacity as a result of the widening
that's taking place
what we're saying is as john has
emphasized is that at the moment the
junction isn't able to reach its
theoretical capacity because the large
vehicles are blocking it and not
allowing it to operate in the way that
it should operate and by widening the
road we will allow the junction to
perform as it should perform
thank you do those large hdvs take into
account the the vehicles that the
clerk was talking about
yes yes we've assessed maximum maximum
hgvs
thank you
thank you very much councilman i think
that's an old hand is it yeah okay we
have no other questions so thank you
very much uh thank you for joining us
and thank you for answering the
questions
okay we now move on um to the ward
member we have councillor sarah mansell
and counselor helen geek would you like
to go first or second i have a written i
have a
i've had a
email to read out would you like me to
do that first i think uh if if that's
right with you chair i think it's pretty
best if you read out uh councillor
geek's comments and then i'll do my bit
and then maybe i can try and answer any
questions or absolutely no that's fine
okay so uh cass geek's unable to make it
today and has sent the following in i'm
really pleased that the planning office
and developer have come to an agreement
about the oak tree which is a very
notable feature of school road and will
currently be supporting a huge number of
species that would have taken many
decades to establish on new trees
this is one of the nicest parts of
elmsworld part of the best views we have
over wonderful rolling open countryside
framed by the oak
and because the landowner and developer
want to build on it and because the
government wants a ridiculous number of
houses built it seems it has to be built
over
locally we've tried to fight this on as
many grounds as we can find
firstly the safety of the access very
near a blind corner on a busy road
secondly the congested school road
junction with its heavy lorry use and
uncertain pedestrian safety
thirdly the effect on the development of
the lands on the landscape and the
lovely view and the setting of the
various listed buildings
fourthly the fact that elmswater has
delivered far more housing already than
the community wants or needs and finally
the lack of primary school places in the
village
all of these reasons are valid and have
weight in planning terms the main reason
that the village of elmsworld don't want
is it
don't want it is that we already have
enough houses in elmswell and this is a
beautiful part of the countryside there
is no clear need for this development
and the benefits do not outweigh the
harm so i would urge the committee to
refuse consent as these are the wrong
houses in the wrong place that's from
councillor helen geek
okay over to you councilman
uh thank you chair um before i read out
the pieces of text i've prepared uh i'd
just like to um
pick up on um some of the other comments
and questions that were made earlier um
john matheson um
asked about the
cycle route and the land that is owned
by sustrans now sustrans bought that
land um about 20 years ago or more
and uh design of cycle routes has
subsequently changed and i do believe
that suffolk county council and sustrans
are looking into what is the best route
choice for that route it may not be on
the land that is already owned by
sustrans
uh councillor stringer um asked about
other developments in elmswell uh i'd
just like to clarify that all
developments in the future of elmswell
will put more traffic through this
junction at school road church road it
is the gateway to the village from the
a14 so wherever you build in the village
there will be traffic going through it
um and the agent commented that this is
an allocated site in our job in our
emerging joint local plan which does now
have more weight but in the joint local
plant it is only allocated for 50 homes
not 86.
uh right i'll now um go on to what i um
was going to say anyway
uh i don't doubt that this developer has
worked well with our officers to try to
provide potential mitigation for some of
the local infrastructure issues which
will be exacerbated by this development
it's great that we've secured the
housing mix in tenure but there are
other issues which money alone can't
solve as it does more harm to something
else
there are a number of things which are
welcome in in the development the
provision of the cycle path along school
road and potentially behind the church
but i am not i'm still to be convinced
of the so-called improvements to the
school road church road junction
the widened road and junction may make
it possible for most traffic to pass one
another safely but not the oversized h.c
wilson hgvs that you've seen in the
photos that were sent
you know they are a regular uh
occurrence in our village uh on monday
of this week uh four of those enormous
silos went past my window
and that you know that's just a typical
day
the highways authority clearly have
struggled to know what to do with this
junction their own projections show that
the junction will become over capacity
with the development in the village but
then they just want to ignore the
figures they first wanted traffic lights
then a roundabout heritage stepped in
and said that they would cause harm to
the setting of the listed buildings so
now we have this widened junction to
enable more vehicles to slew around the
corner at higher speed
i understand that that corner was built
out over 20 years ago to slow traffic
down so here here we are going to speed
it all up again
i have my doubts about the regard for
pedestrian safety at this junction
is currently not a nice place to try to
cross the road but once it's widened it
will become even more dangerous there
are drop curbs shown on the plans but
the visibility is poor even with the
proposed build out of the curb on the
eastern side having visited the site
this morning you cannot see traffic
coming along school road if you're
standing where that drop kerb is going
to be
and if there are parked vehicles along
church road as there would be if there
was a church service you wouldn't be
able to see along church road either
even miss balboa said that it was the
best location possible but still not
necessarily safe
it is great that we have agreement to
save the oak tree but i hope that the
guarantee that the works to create the
cycle path and the road scheme are not
going to damage the routes
sensitive landscaping will be needed on
the western edge of the development and
along this school road
aspect as this is one of the key views
out of the village across open farmland
planting a load of vegetation here could
disrupt that view
and i do hope that the road narrowing at
the tree has the desired effect of
calming traffic before it goes around
that right angle bend
the only way to truly mitigate the issue
of this junction is either to bypass it
or to get people out of their cars a
bypass is neither financially nor
environmentally sustainable so we are
left with the alternative to try to
shift to more sustainable modes of
transport and that just isn't going to
happen if children living in this
village have to be transported to
woolpit for schooling this really is not
a sustainable development
there is all also the matter of timing
this new school in woolpit will not be
completed before occupation of the new
housing in elmswell so what is the
interim solution to the schooling
problem children will end up being
transported even further afield again
that's not sustainable the committed
developments in elmswell have already
pushed the infrastructure well over
capacity and enough has to be enough
when will it ever stop this development
is one too many for elmswell
thank you
thank you councilman so do we have any
question for the ward members
nope okay thank you very much thank you
councilman okay so we're going to move
on now um
it's now open i now like to open it up
for debate um if you wish to make a
proposal please just put your hand up um
enable members to discuss debate and
obviously we need to come to a
conclusion
um
on the application before us so first of
all we have counselor passmore
um thank you very much matthew this is a
well been a very good discussion very
long one of course we did debated it in
detail i think it was a couple of months
ago
and um i am really pleased the tree has
been preserved and i'm also
encouraged to hear the comments by the
planning officer john payton g regarding
the landscaping which needs to be done
tastefully if the committee has agreed
to to do this um as i said earlier so i
think that's a really important point
i do still have concerns about the
junction like i think many of
our councillor colleagues do have
there will be more traffic and um
i think i did hear the officer say
what's in the papers
that there will be an enhanced
um
how can we put it
does it part of the decision-making
process where our planning officers can
make sure this junction really is safe
and i think that's absolutely crucial
i think i'm balanced chairman in order
to move the debate along i'm going to
propose that we um that we do grant
planning permission for this but i do
want to put a couple of caveats on this
um to really re-emphasize the point
about the landscaping and the tree
preservation
i am concerned about the
traffic and the safety at the junction
so i'd like that as part of the
condition i think it's recommended in
the papers that our planning authority
is fully involved in
making sure that that junction is safe
now i'm not a highways engineers but
obviously that has to be delegated
because we do need to make a decision on
this
i completely understand i think um sarah
manson and helen geeks
concerns it's always a difficult issue
this and elmsworld has had a lot of
development but looking at it in the
longer term the fact that it does
support that mix of housing which it
doesn't have to do and i think there is
a positive message there and i recognize
the work that's been put in by
our people as well as the applicants um
i think overall it
is something that i would therefore
support so i'm formally proposing
chairman that we do grant planning
commission thank you very much
thank you very much uh councillor matson
you're next
thank you chair yes i
i was reading one once again the the um
the issue of correctly balancing the
various policies and
i did want to ask
first
um
and i think the proposal was a bit
premature quite honestly when we haven't
actually debated yet
um
that asked mr paytman g
that the is is our policy fc one
is that consistent or inconsistent with
the mppf paragraph 11
which is discussed at the bottom of page
32 and the top of page 33
and i just wasn't clear
that was having read
these arguments so many times about the
tilted balance and all the rest of it
um i i just wanted to understand that if
i could
please
sorry bear with me just a moment
apologies i'm
just having a few technical difficulties
[Music]
obviously the um the tests of the the
various uh policies is our judgment but
the when we look at the appeal history
on many of them um
fc one doesn't actually come up that
much we know we we know how inconsistent
we are in respect of h7 and um
cs1 and under those policies
um the
fce one is a is a later policy that was
actually made at the point of the nppf
coming into effect
bear with me just one more moment i just
need to
reread it one more time and it's full um
if this computer allows me to do it
gemma can you help me yeah did you want
me to comment on this one so fc one was
written
as john mentioned at some time to the
first version of the mppf so it did
originally pick up the sustainability
requirements expected by the mppf
in the meantime we've had a revised mppf
which we're now looking at paragraph 11
and because that doesn't match in the
same way the revised word in the mppf
inspectors have
found against it to at least some degree
so i'd say we should be giving that less
weight because it doesn't fully accord
with the mppf so really the mppf wording
is what we need to give due regard to
there does that help okay yes okay thank
you yes thank you for that i appreciate
that
um counselor muller
thank you chair um i must admit i'm
delighted to see that a tree
preservation order is being placed on
the oak tree which is great news i
appreciate there are a lot of concerns
about the junction and the number of
large hdv vehicles using this particular
road but i feel that the the measure the
measures being put in place or
recommended for it put in place do
actually improve the road junction um
considerably to what it is actually at
the moment
um therefore i must admit i'm happy to
second councillor pasmore's proposal um
forex for approval for this particular
development thank you chair
thank you councillor field
thank you
i find
we seem to have made a number of
improvements since the last time we
looked at this application uh
particularly around the tree and the
road widening so i'm pleased to see that
um we have been told by remember i think
in the parish perhaps that uh elsewhere
has enough houses we don't need any well
certainly uh many of us own houses and
don't need any more but i don't see
great rafts of empty dwellings
indicating that there's a surplus of
capacity you know many young people who
to my mind could very well do with
affordable housing and currently have to
move back with their families i'm into
the shortage so i'm not convinced that
argument
holds weight
on the junction however i i certainly
continue to have doubts
um
there's been a
various proposals many roundabouts
traffic lights whatever so people have
been
searching for a solution
they wouldn't be searching if there
wasn't a problem
so there does seem to be a difficulty
here and i would sort of suggest that
the mppf
kick um conditions on on the on highways
are
that the capacity issue shall not be
severe but the way i read it the
safety
condition is that road safety that
should not have an unacceptable
impact on road safety it doesn't mention
severe in that case so
i think we could safely take that into
account
clearly
changes to the junction width will will
allow perhaps two vehicles to pass
without an actual conflict without them
stopping at the
point where one is exiting and another
trying to enter so that does seem to be
an improvement but there's significant
question to me about that is that
improvement adequate
certainly if it leaves 18 vehicle cues
still there's some question
on the school capacity and the use of
using a private car will we ever move
away from that and get to a more
environmentally sustainable position
well elmsworld does have a railway
station
and it's not impossible to take children
by a car even if you have to do that to
to a wool pit and i guess you could do
that in
more than one in a vehicle
it's not impossible and they could cycle
on the cycle track so that's not
impossible
i find i'm a bit torn i shall make my
mind up in the next few minutes but um
it's the road junction safety issues
that really
are the thing that i think is a
detractor to this
development
otherwise i'll prepare be prepared to
see it go ahead and vote for it
thank you
thanks very much um did you want to come
in donald gemma on i
was anything you wanted to come in on at
this point
um perhaps just to check through the
recommendation with counselor passport
and councilman muller just to check that
we've got all the points so um
the recommendation is on page 43 to 45.
i think i've got that right um
and it as the officer recommendation
from conscious counsellor pastor i
mentioned landscaping and highways and i
really wanted to clarify that because
the landscaping would really be dealt
with by reserve matters so did are you
happy with that or did you want
something further
well the thanksgiving
the question i said to john i think
right back at the beginning of um when
it was just for questions is just to
make sure it really is a high quality
landscaping scheme i don't know i know
it's there as a as a reserve master but
i just wanted to emphasize that point is
there anything you can do to make sure
you can work with the developer if it
gets approved by the committee to make
sure it's really a very good scheme
we've got no reason to doubt it and on
the highways i'm sure somewhere in the
papers i read them
yesterday when i was looking through
there is an option or a possibility that
um
you know you and your colleagues could
be involved in making sure
that the safety at that junction is
absolutely maximized rather than just
leave it to the um
um
to the to the highways people and so on
so that it tries to address the concerns
i think that john feel well everybody
has actually said on that
sure
yeah no that's helpful thank you so much
that wasn't meant to
do it as an informal informative note
exactly just what i was going to say so
we'll have an informative note about the
landscaping um and how that comes
forward through the reserve matters and
then the highways we've we've got that
conditioned i think i think adequately
we've got it under the 278 works through
the section 106 and then there are
various highways conditions about the
implementation so i
i do think they are covered if you're
happy with that yeah that's perfect
recommendation as
as
proposed on 43-45 with an informative
note about the landscaping um
high quality landscaping agreed is that
okay yes thank you thank you i have
plenty of people that wish to speak so
councillor stringer next
thank you chair
uh
it's always uh often uh these committees
we always uh uh sort of tussle with with
very fine arguments uh where things are
finally balanced uh and of course we
should because that's why we're here
and what what we're tasked with doing is
is looking at conflicting policies often
apportioning weight to them as as as we
think and as the evidence shows us to
then come to a recent decision and this
one is an incredibly unbalanced decision
i feel probably one of the most
unbalanced ones i've seen in a number of
years
so if i start with the pluses
first of all congratulate the applicant
for actually trying to work with
officers etc to try and reach a reasoned
decision i think that's that's to be
applauded
um
also i was really pleased to hear that
during our legal uh legal intervention
that common sense can be used in terms
of looking at things in the planning
system for me that is a first
so
i also think
so on the plus side we've got a
genuinely good mix of houses we've got
it on a site that's technically in a
joint local plan even though in draft
form
uh et cetera et cetera we then come to
the miners side
uh and there are for me there are two
elements of the minor side the minus
side is the road junction at school road
church road uh and that has
for the whole of elmsley that is the
elephant in the room here of how you
address that
uh
and of course the scheme that we now
have in front of us been through various
iterations they've now got to a position
where we basically go back a few decades
and we we put in a scheme that was there
a few decades ago that had to be amended
back then because of the speed of the
traffic using the junction
but we also have a scheme here and we're
asked to agree a plan that also has not
been through a safety audit
and that safety audit will have to take
into account the possible speeds of the
traffic at the junction as well as
visibility etc
what we also have as a vital material
consideration is deliverability
and mid-suffolk and suffolk as a whole
is littered with schemes just like this
where we have
an approval for planning permission in
the wind but without
vital infrastructure going through a
safety audit and we have a number of
them that are held back by the fact the
safety audit cannot be ticked yes it's
safe
so the mpps very strict about
deliverability it says you should be
approving deliverable sites
deliverability is a very very big thing
we have to each year tell government how
many houses we're delivering
so for me on very fine balance
i would i couldn't support this in its
present form because that key
infrastructure
is not been through the safety audit and
is not deliverable therefore this scheme
may be undeliverable in its present form
uh that's where i am chair and thank you
for the ability to speak
cancer stringer councilman you're next
thanks chair uh i think the scheme's got
a lot in its favor um it is a good mix
of houses it is in the emerging joint
local plan and it is sustainable you
could quite happily live in this village
and not own a motor car um what hasn't
been mentioned is is the large scale
co-op is available you could you know
work in it switch you could work in
cambridge
you know so for me it's quite an
attractive location
having said that the junction is the
issue
junction
widening has been uh improvements have
been suggested
but this will speed up cars taking that
corner coming up the hill from the wall
pit um roundabout
so i'm very concerned about
is that junction safe is it safe for
pedestrians
and
i find it
very concerning that we're told that
there could be a stage 3 safety audit
after the junk after the pedestrian
crossing has been built
to check that it is safe well we're
talking about arms houses on one side of
the road with potentially elderly people
in church on the other side of the road
are we really saying that we're going to
wait
until the crossing has been built
to check that it's safe we could
actually have ward members losing their
lives on that junction as cars speed
around the corner because we've widened
the corner
i don't think it's appropriate that we
move this forward until we've had that
safety audit we need to know is that
junction safe and is the pedestrian
crossing workable
so i couldn't support it merely on the
junction i think it's a good site but i
think the junction needs to be
demonstrated safety prior to us awarding
planning permission
okay let's just have clarity around that
point in the audit then please john
um is luke still here as well he might
be able to add the detail behind this
but ultimately you have
free
safety audits you have safety order one
and two which happen prior to
uh the work so it's safety audit free
that has to be after the works because
ultimately it's the assessment of
any uh how efficient those works have
been and any other changes that might be
necessary
um that need to then go forward on that
can you help me out luke just explain
that system to members a little bit more
yeah now that is entirely correct yeah
yeah safety audit one is on um
it is sometimes done on on a concept uh
the safety audit two stage is done on
the detailed design so that would
consider and and that would um
they would involve both of those would
involve site visits so a qualified
safety auditor that has gone through a
sort of set um
set training and set level of
responsibilities um would assess the
safety of the proposal on site
at the detail design stage
armed with all of the detailed design
drawings you know covering every aspect
of the uh the proposal they would then
um make recommendations um and
potentially ask the designers to
incorporate changes to to address any
residual safety concerns so the
as as as much as anything can be
you know um
have have its safety record thoroughly
scrutinized
the design is fully safety audited by
qualified people before
they're given before anybody would be
given road space to construct anything
on the highway network in suffolk the
stage 3 safety order is is just a
further check that nothing that couldn't
have been foreseen during the detailed
design stage having visited on site
remains and as i said there's also a
full fourth safety audit stage which is
often carried out
maybe 18 months 24 months after the
implementation just to check what the
safety record is um
to see if any any incidents have have
occurred and then that also would
recommend any any changes
um so yeah that and like say the the
drawing that that has been shown is
it is a concept it shows the form of the
uh the junction that's needed the
detailed design of that would be a
matter of discharge conditions which
obviously the local planning authority
lead or in consultation with the highway
authority so
opportunities to address like say
residual safety issues in terms of
the speed of traffic through the
junction
will will be addressed through that 278
process and and to discharge your
conditions
did you want to come back councillor
mayor yes please given that this
junction seems to be the the critical
aspect in this planning permission
application
is it possible to say that we wish to
um reserve judgment on the planning
application until the stage one and two
safety audits have been completed
um that has never been my experience in
suffolk um
you know it is it is normal to to
establish um at the outline stage what
the what the concept is going to be for
a junction but then um
you know the safety audit process would
be um controlled through the 278 process
that's that after permission has been
granted but before permission
has been granted by the home authority
under the 278 agreement the those those
vital safety checks would would be would
be carried out um and that would also be
used to inform the discharge of
conditions by the local planning
authority
okay i mean i i still remain concerned
in that
we've had traffic lights dismissed we've
had roundabouts dismissed um i i just
personally i feel like i've been asked
to make a decision
without sufficient information about the
safety of that junction
but yeah
thanks well i i all i'd say is that the
officers are telling you that this is
the standard way that all junctions are
looked at and uh
this is this is the process that
everything goes through through
a series of four stages of audit
so this is this isn't unique to this
location i guess is the message
um okay councillor matheson then
councillor possible
thank you
can can i first ask um
that if we if we seem to be moving
towards a vote and particularly a vote
to approve i've got a number of of
detailed points on on the conditions
um which i wouldn't necessarily want to
rehearse yet unless we we are going to
but when we moved if we could ask a
chair that we do keep a moment or three
back to to actually talk about those
points
regarding the principle um of of this
application and time
i
i feel this the problems remain
that really
the junction is so difficult
um that
why why do we not wait
until modal shift has been achieved um
towards buses and trains so that a
traffic assessment would show
a lesser problem than we we are seeing
at the moment that's the first problem
that i i would pose
why we should perhaps not not go for it
at this time
after all the joint local plan emerging
is up to 2036
so we're 15 years short of that
there's time to come back to this one
um
the has been mentioned a couple of times
the mismatch of the location of this of
the school places compared to the um to
the
the children that will will in due
course appear
um the school is in wool pit
the houses are in elmswell um that's a
repeated problem
which we're not doing anything to
address by putting another um
however many is 80 odd here
um
councilman is
rightly dwelling on the the
the pedestrian safety at the junction i
i won't need to add to that except that
yes yes there's a real worry there
but the the fourth particular point is
something that we haven't really talked
about yet
and that is the the what one was
described as the village's aspiration
for a bypass and what i wanted to
to point to if i can just find the right
ref the right page a moment
um
the the in in discussing and dismissing
in the report
the um
this the whether the the there is
justified to consider
the the parish's wish
which is yet to be turned into um into
firm policy anywhere for to to haven't
have a bypass
oh yes
page 38 if you if you could look uh in
in the
towards the top of that page
um there is there is a description of of
what good of good planning
and it says
some of this potential that's the
potential for getting things right
essentially
some of this potential is not material
for the decision now but good planning
is about ensuring the future opportunity
for good design and development is not
lost and i i think the the point that
the parish are making that this would
this this particular
development would
preclude the most advantageous possible
future bypass
i think that we do need to weigh that
it is very clear statement i don't know
where it's come from but good planning
is about ensuring the future opportunity
for good design and development is not
lost
which is what would be happening if we
go ahead thank you
thank you uh councillor
yeah thanks matthew just wanted to come
back what i was really trying to do when
we talked about the informative note
that gemma um kindly mentioned it really
is to try and address this difficulty
over the junction as
so that it is actually safe because
it's difficult to sit here as members
just giving every little detail but i i
think it was um
richard mayer said about right angle
corners those details i absolutely agree
with andrew and his safety comments and
john and everybody else we're all
concerned about that so i just really
wanted to emphasize what i was trying to
do was to make sure that we get a really
good satisfactory solution
for the junction so that it is safe for
all road users which of course includes
pedestrian cyclists
hgvs and motorists so i really hope that
does cover it it wasn't intended to be
just a comment chair may i come in on
that please if i may
um okay so in the recommendation the
last condition in the recommendation
uh essentially says if i quickly bring
it up i should have done that before i
started coming talking
so the last condition uh says the final
details of school road and church road
junction and widening to be agreed now
that's you know in terms of one line
that's quite broad brush but essentially
what we are doing in this case which i
will tell you now
it's probably the second time in my
career that we've done this is that we
are not solely leaving this to the
highways authority
okay and it's not because we don't trust
the highways authority i wouldn't want
to say that at all it's purely because
we are recognizing the importance
of this particular
detail to get it right from an amenity
point of view from a safety point of
view from from a traffic point of view
and from you know design point of view
on an important edge of of elmsworld
which does have the list of buildings
nearby to consider it does have the um
the the tree and it does have uh the
open landscape we are therefore feeling
justified to want to be involved in that
process when normally we'd let it sail
off to the highways authority alone to
resolve those finer details and that is
what we have done the only other time we
did get a bit more involved was actually
imposed upon us by the wall pit appeal
in respect of the traffic calming scheme
there that's the only other time i think
that we came down to dealing with the
detail unfortunately in that case that
we had a lot of constraints because the
uh condition that was written by the
appeal inspector was constrained to a
specific drawing and we could only work
from that drawing in general terms in
this case we are still you know we have
drawings we have plans we have an idea
where this is going but the finer
details we do have the ability to work
with the highways and applicants to
ensure that we are committed to what
we've said to here which is to ensure
this is as safe as it can be and an
improvement on the current situation
thanks very much thank you thank you for
that uh council stringer
yeah don't wish to prolong this too too
much but actually this is the real
number of this this particular case
and the health the explanation of stage
one and stage two safety audits are
really helpful
the nub of it is if you approve a
planning permission
you cannot take it back
if you haven't had a schemes
safety audited
it may be safer but it may not be safe
so you are being asked potentially to
approve something that will be proved
unsafe
at the stage toward it and we're being
told that that's process that's how it
normally happens yes we know that's how
it normally happens just clear andrea i
don't think that's right we're we're
it's stage three audit stage one and two
are done
[Music]
stage two is done before it's built
stage three and four are after yes so
that's what i'm saying stage two is done
in between the approval and being built
right that is the problem chair
stage two needs to be done before we
give it approval because if stage two
comes back and it says this design is
unsafe
which is what the engineers found 20
years ago
this design is unsafe
therefore we've got an approval that we
can't go back on what the committee
wants to do is to be able to approve a
safe scheme
and that is
so i've got a question to john patman g
so can we give permission subject to
stage two
coming out uh
showing that the junction is safe
so we grant permission subject that we
want confirmation that stage two shows
that the junction is safe and if it is
not safe then it comes back to committee
so a minded to recommendation sorry for
stepping in chair i know you asked john
well i'm just saying can we approve it
uh if if that's the decision of the
committee if we go down that route that
we approve this but subject to stage two
showing that the junction is safe
and if if it shows the junction isn't
safe then it has to come back to
committee
because effective and then that sort of
rules out then that takes care of
andrew's point council stringer's point
that we've got clarity that the junction
is safe at stage two so it's permission
is granted
subject to obviously what members vote
but subject to stage two showing that
the junction is safe
in my head i'm still trying to work out
if we are looking at a process of
granting permission but maybe we have a
condition that says you can't build any
houses unless the stage two is completed
and satisfied or we're looking at a
delegation to get that detail before we
actually issue the decision i'm not
quite sure which approach
is to do that then that takes care of
the point that council stringers
made
and it would work
i'd be happy with it yeah i think it's a
good idea if we can do that
and if sorry chairman if i may step in
as legal advisor in the effects is what
being suggested is being suggested is in
effect a slightly a more not a grampian
condition although not of the more
common kind
is
if i'm honest to give the reassurance
that the i would probably prefer the
condition route but i would i think i'm
going to ask gemma and ian for a further
opinion on that because i'd not come
across this situation before
no i think that's that we we might just
need five ten minutes to take that away
chair and work through the the various
options i think the three of us have
probably could do with that
pass more
i don't care how it's done as long as
it's safe
can we um
ten minutes chair i appreciate this for
belonging to this in order to give you
the correct advice about which
you get it right and you've heard the
concerns and there is a big concern
there and if that helps with the concern
then
then it's a way forward
okay um if you don't mind yes if we
could possibly have ten minutes um yeah
so we'll start again at 12 o'clock thank
you thank you
uh
all right thank you chair i'll now
conduct role call of members
to make sure they're back after the
break so
counselor mayor
president councilman muller
thank you chair we're all here from
memphis right
thank you very much okay so um over to
gemma i guess or to mr dupres
thanks uh
chair um yeah thank you for the break
that was very helpful for us just to go
through and work out the
um
most effective way of delivering this um
you know given members concerns about
this and i think we probably have
actually got a third suggestion of what
we would um
suggest looking at in order to deliver
that and give members that confidence
that this is something that is within
our control and something that we can
look at at the appropriate time so what
we would suggest is that this is
actually
further detailed in the section 106 and
that the stage 2 safety audit would be
required to be agreed concurrent with
the submission of the first reserve
matters application
and that then the junction would be
subject to delivery prior to first
occupation of any dwelling
i hope that was just run through that
again so through the section one just
say that again the earlier yep so your
your stage two safety audit would be
subject to 106 agreement so it would be
part of the legal agreement and that
stage 2 safety audit would be required
to be agreed concurrent with the first
reserve matters
application
so that at the time that we're looking
at the design of those houses and that
comes to committee we will have that
detail of the safety audit of the
junction
and then the second part is that that
junction has agreed
through that design process would be
delivered prior to the first occupation
of any dwelling
so basically it will come back with
reserve matters and by at that point it
will have to be proven to know that it
works
yes yeah okay
um councillor passmore and councillor
muller what are your thoughts on that
are you happy with that as a way forward
i i think that will be fine yeah yeah i
think that covers it all and that's what
we were concerned about yeah definitely
a counselor stringer you want to come in
yeah uh thank you chair sorry to be
pedantic uh um
could i ask i still don't think it
covers it what happens
if the second stage audit comes back and
it says it is unsafe you have an
approved outline permission
no because it it would come back to
reserve man it would come back as
reserved matters it would come back
under reserve matters to members sorry
because that way you would have an
approved outline application
that's incapable of of
getting to the next stage you can't do
that you're not you're not allowed to do
that this is why we're putting it into
the 106 as opposed to a condition so
this is this is the whole point of of
making sure that it's in the right uh
legality legal area for us to ensure
that you can't go any further past stop
if the stop sign is put up so so so
actually then you know if it's part of
the 106 you don't get your approval
until the 106 is signed is that correct
or if i may chairman if i can button now
i think it i wasn't
i was um available to my colleagues but
i left them to work out this little
detail but the the point is you can use
a 106 agreement can in effect say
although there is a planning permission
it might not get implemented and if i'm
reading the minds of my colleagues that
is that your attention that that was our
intention because obviously that's why
we thought the 106 route would be the
more
safer and confident route that we could
take that we would consider
so just to be 100 if it doesn't meet
stage two
it can't go any further because of the
section 106. so hopefully that covers
your point andrew that clarity is very
helpful thank you thank you
okay we have one other hand um counselor
madison
yeah i'm i'm no lawyer clearly but i
just wonder whether whether the form of
the 106 is actually is actually that um
the chief planning office has got a
delega delegated authority to to refuse
if the safety audit fails really is that
perhaps what what's gemma suggesting
um
no we're not we are we are right we are
suggesting we grant planning permission
but the control is put into the 106
agreement
ultimately
and i will just mention this we actually
when we were talking offline we were
talking to the chief planning officer at
the same time about this
so we are confident and and clear and
ultimately with the 106 agreement the
applicant has to sign up to it and also
the county council will be party to it
as well
and if chairman if i might i mean
council council stringer is quite right
in as a general principle if you grant
an outline permission then you are
saying in principle up to that number of
houses maybe not the whole number if as
a push will have to be allowed under
reserve matters somehow but the section
106 agreement
alters that and says although although
there isn't there there is going to be
an outline permission it is subject to
this
might on a worst case scenario uh
prevent it
it's unusual but it's lawful and it
seems to be the best solution of dealing
with this conundrum
all right we don't have any other hands
up so i propose i am proposing that we
go to a vote but john did you want
before we do that you said there were a
couple of things you wanted to tee off
yes yes yes please chair
um
right um let's just get there nothing
nice
um
yeah i'm quite happy the officers may
say that some of these things that want
to go to the reserve matters um but
possibly some of them don't so if we
could just go through them
um the the on page 126
that there's a there's a request that
the
the travel plan
coordinator that would be appointed um
should engage with others um other
travel plan coordinators in this area
and i i wondered how the the mechanism
for that might be provided that was that
was the first one
um
then the sustainable efficiency measures
just to clarify that we
um
they are as set out on page 208
but i did want to
ask
mr paintman g whether he he put forward
a suggestion two weeks ago committee um
that the the sustainable efficiency
measures might um
might come forward with
it what was it concurrent with
concurrent with the the reserve matters
application so that they were thought
through fully
uh before the the thing was finalized
that was that was that one there and
then the
other question
is um yes that we
page 127 on the travel plan that the the
um the
the bullet let's see now this is a 106
point
says framework and detailed travel plan
um and that should be including travel
packs hopefully that that follows but
that's uh but the the the trickiest one
is fourth last one
is on the um
the housing mix
um to be in accordance with the
strategic et cetera et cetera on page
44.
can we can we at this stage
or at the latest stage
require
two
part m3
wheelchair user dwellings
and also two part m2
um accessible and adaptable dwellings
yes finished
yeah okay i think we've got to be
careful of i mean
we're not we're not here to rewrite the
whole thing now uh i'm not i'm adding
okay yes but
but there's a limit uh john
do you want to just comment on what is
included already and then we'll have to
go to him but between me and gemma we
can do this um ultimately in terms of
the travel plan that is part of the 106
anyway and the uh negotiations about
those elements will be part of that with
agreement with the county in any event
so i'm not really
needing to unpack that i don't think
because i think that's already covered
in terms of the
sustainability condition within your
recommendation
yes i did
last time say we could change that to be
concurrent with the first reserve
matters
i see no reason why we couldn't do that
here unless gemma has any other thoughts
but i think that's that's just that's a
straight matter of timing we can add
that in to ensure that it's a concurrent
um and ultimately with regard to the
access issues the final design or
appearance scale um and and so on in
respect of the properties uh of course
they need to be compliant with building
control which picks up on disability but
um
ultimately i would suggest that is there
is a matter point that can be picked up
later uh but it isn't a specific point i
would suggest we need to make now in
terms of the mix in terms of bedroom
numbers and so on that we need to look
at now okay thank you yeah that's that
thank you in the main i did when i read
the building regulations on this point
john it did not it should be part of the
permission although it was in the
building rig so that was a i'm not clear
about what that means exactly but i i
just rely that officers will get us to
the yeah that's that at the right point
whenever it is
thank you okay
um any other points before we go to a
vote
council no pass more happy with with the
concurrent
yeah by all means use that word
it makes a significant difference we
think okay john
uh so i'm just going to ask uh now we've
had it proposed by councillor passmore
and second and
um uh just look at seconded by
councillor muller um as per the
recommendations on page 43 44 and 45 of
our papers but with the addition of a
couple of points and gemma will you just
reconfirm those points please so we're
absolutely clear of course so the first
point was we'll have an informative note
about the high quality landscaping to be
agreed
then we've got the amendment to the
section 106 aspect in terms of the stage
2 safety audit and the delivery of the
junction as we discussed and then we've
got the uh slight addition to the
sustainability condition that that would
be agreed concurrent with the reserve
matters
thank you thank you very much thank you
okay i'll now hand over um
to the monitoring officer sorry to um
robert carmichael to take an electronic
vote
for the governance officer
thank you chair i don't think i've been
promoted quite yet
so um if members could please go to the
modern.gov app before we start i would
just like to check council stringer have
you uh been able to get into bond.gov
i believe i have it keeps throwing me
out but i keep going back in
brilliant thank you counselor so i will
now if members could go to the
attendance and voting tab
and i will now start
start the vote
it should appear now in a light blue
color
robert it's logged me out over the top
as well i'm afraid i think we just go
let's locked me out because we've been
so long so i think we're going to have
to do a
manual vote okay that's absolutely fine
so if members could please um i already
have received two votes um so i won't
repeat those ones in there but these
will be recorded and i will add them in
after the meeting for clarity's sake
so for the people who have not voted
could i please ask councillor hicks for
your vote
councillor sarah mansell oh sorry
councilman so apologies it's in the list
that's a councillor matheson
against
councillor
i think councillor passmore has just
voted yeah
thank you and then finally and council
stringer just to check that you've
gotten voted as well because i've seen
you on i have yeah
so thank you chair
that is carried by
six votes to one
okay thank you very much
right and we're going to move swiftly on
then thank you everyone we're going to
move on to the next application which is
dc283704
land west of the old norwich road
whitton and now i'd like to invite the
case officer bradley heffer to introduce
the application to committee bradley
over to you
thank you very much chair um good
afternoon members um
i'll just share my
screen hopefully if you could just
say when you can see that it's okay
apologies
be able to see the presentation
yeah yes we are thank you it's not in
presentation mode though no no i'll just
adjust that
right
okay
yeah so good afternoon members ladies
and gentlemen um
this application is a reserve matters
proposal you're being asked to consider
for 190 dwellings on a site of old
norwich road in whitten
the high level location view you can see
in front of you shows the site
and shows if you can see my cursor
hopefully you can
the edge of what is in effect
ipswich
at this point witton
um and there's the site we're talking
about and there's the
a14
trunk road
and this is the roundabout that serves
angular retail park asda and various
other businesses and to the north here
you can see on the plan
clayden
the larger scale plan
shows the line of old norwich road
which would where the access would be
taken from
um
and also at this point it's useful to
point out i've had a chance to read
through my report that this site follows
on from an outline planning application
to do to develop a larger site which
also included the piece of land in this
triangle to the north
it was refused by um
councillors at the committee
went to appeal and the subsequent appeal
was
successful in so far as it related to
this part of the site
so in effect the developer sorry the
inspector issued a split decision
and allowed development on this part of
the site but saw fit to refuse
development on the triangular piece
to the north
the constraints map um there's not many
constraints as such to talk about i mean
the the black line you can see here is
the edge of ipswich borough uh you'll
see the site
uh
abuts uh it's which borough there um not
too clear unfortunately on the plan but
there is a public footpath which runs
part of the way along here
and out onto ipswich road
and you'll see that there are also
some historic
heritage assets i listed buildings
on the plan
within mid-suffolk
but they're well away from the site
itself
the nearest heritage asset to this site
is actually within whitton which as i
said is in ipswich borough
there's a conservation area which
contains various listed buildings
at this part basically on the road
junction
this is the redline site
and just to advise in terms of that it's
a 10 hectare site approximately and 1.8
hectares of that would be given to open
space
as part of the planning approval granted
appeal the inspectors all fit to
identify a parameters plan which had
been submitted i understand at the time
of the appeal
and basically
suggested that this should be the way
that development on this site is guided
so as you will see just to pick out the
salient points this darker color here
is proposed that development up to three
stories could take place here
the lighter strip you see here
development up to two stories so in
effect the residential development would
be taking place in that chunk
this area here
would be given over to open space
vehicle access would take place off of
this point here
and this plan also identifies the
existing
planting which is on the site shown in
green
so there are parameters in place that
must guide
the reserve matters proposals
that's resulted in the production of the
master plan
and if i quickly flick to the coloured
one it's probably
a bit clearer for you
this shows the means of access from old
norwich road
leading through a spine and spine
arrangement up to that point there with
smaller status roads leading off
various perimeter blocks and linear
development
and as you can see to the south here
there is the
open space
dwellings are detached semi-detached and
there are
some
terraces
um the annotation of this plan is
different and i should point out that
east
is north
if that makes sense but this will give
you an idea of the proposed landscaping
scheme for the site um as you'd expect
with a scheme of this size that involves
sustainable drainage
um and this is the the basin that
would be part of that arrangement
um you'll also see the larger area of
open space
as i've mentioned before
and there's
a number of trees that would be proposed
as part of the landscaping scheme within
the new residential area
as identified in my report there's
character areas that being
created within the site
the lighter green is the more formal
areas which is known as the street the
darker green is the less formalized
development so there's two distinct air
well two areas of character that are
being created within the site to add um
some visual interest
um the permanent permeability plan i'll
put this in there because it shows
basically where the pink lines
would be
the routes that pedestrians would take
and other alternative routes off the
site would be available um in blue as
its planned access across the open space
and as i said before there's a lot of a
public footpath that runs across here
and these would link in with the line of
the public footpath
um just quickly the affordable housing
plan we've had some discussions with the
developer about the location not the
amount because that's fixed in the
section 106 and it meets the
policy requirement but when the
application first came in it was a lot
more concentrated in one location
um and through negotiation um it's been
moved across the site
and the um the strategic housing team
are happier or you know they're content
with the what's shown on that that
drawing just so that you're aware the
red
dwellings are the shared ownership units
and the blue ones the affordable rent
story heights
pink is two-story
yellow is one story as i said
with a parameters plan that did
recognize up to three story development
could be provided on the site but
there's no instances of three-story
development here
boundary treatments this looks amazingly
complicated but the reason i've put this
on is that it indicates on this line
here
where the acoustic fence would go in
the details of that have to be agreed as
part of the condition that was imposed
on the outline planning application and
as members will appreciate that's in
order to deal with the impact of the
trunk road which runs adjacent to the
site on this side
excuse me i think the other points to a
point as where you've got key areas
within the public realm they're actually
using
was proposed to use walling which is
green as opposed to um other sorts of
enclosure like close boarded fencing so
um
i think in terms of the overall value of
the scheme that certainly helps
the parking strategy just quickly to go
through this the each
unit either benefits from a garage
and associated space so the garages are
shown in the yellowish color
the associated spaces are showing green
um visitor spaces are shown in the
orange color here and the other thing
worth pointing out is where dwellings
don't benefit from a garage
for example along this boundary
and here you'll see small blue dots and
that's actually shed provision so that
there will be secure cycle parking for
all the units
um charging points the
proposal includes vehicle charging
points in every garage
and where garages aren't provided uh for
example in shed or or
parking areas to the front
um you'll see that there's standalone
charging units to be provided or in the
cases of individual units where garages
aren't where they've got on plot parking
there's um charging points proposed on
flank walls but again
every
unit in effect has got um charging or
not the visitor spaces but certainly the
um the resident spaces have got charging
points
i'll quickly run through the design as
you can see it's
a traditional um architectural approach
that's being taken
with regard to
the scheme
the street scenes enable you to
understand the the the undulating nature
of the proposal sorry the application
site um it's taller towards um
or higher towards the the trunk road and
then falls down
towards um old norwich road
um i'll quickly run through these um as
you say as you can see they're all
traditionally formed buildings uh brick
with tiled roofs
and no doubt members have have seen this
sort of development proposal before but
in terms of context
we're happy that um these will sit there
quite comfortably and not appear in
congress in this location
and lastly
some photographs of the site this is
looking southwards along
old norwich road
and there's a sweep along the road
this is approximately where the x the
access into the site will be coming in
looking again southwards
across the site across the road
you can't fail to notice obviously the
the pylons which are the
uh main feature within the landscape
um
and this is looking up the road again
you'll see and if you've read in my
report
old norwich road is part of the sus
trans route so therefore there's a
pedestrian sorry a cycle lane within the
highway
that carries that forward backwards and
forwards through the bus gate which is
at the end of old narrage road and
limits the amount of traffic that can
use norwich road
a sweep across the site itself from the
road
again you hopefully get some sort of
flavor of the height change as you get
towards the a14 which is in the distance
here
um and that is the feature along the the
northern boundary
which would be retained as part of the
the planning application proposals
um and this house here is the nearest
house to the access which
on on this photograph be coming in
approximately at this point
and there's another view there
i've put this photograph in because as
you go along the ribbon of development
along the road here between two houses
there is a gap
which is
and access to the field at the rear but
it isn't part of the public right-of-way
network
i'm i'm not sure to be honest whether it
was a an old agricultural access but um
as part of the proposals this wouldn't
be used as a means of access and the
plan would show um close boarded fencing
at the end here to stop this off but i
thought it's worth just showing you that
and again there's a last view of the
site which is looking adjacent to
the first house to the north where the
where the access comes in and you can in
the background there you can see the um
the the white hall i think it's
industrial estate
in the distance um the only thing i
would say is hopefully you've had a
chance to look at the um the late
representation sheet
which identifies that there's um
we've now had confirmation
from the
um
the suffolk archaeology that they have
agreed in a position uh with regard to
archaeological investigation on the site
with the developer notwithstanding the
condition that was put in by the um
the inspector at the time
not being seen as being fit for purpose
so i'm pleased to be able to advise
there is an agreed position on that
um i've also added in there that the
strategic housing team has no objection
to the proposals we hadn't had that
available unfortunately when i did my
report
and also i've slightly adjusted the
recommended conditions and the reason
i've done that as you can see is that
they repeat conditions that were imposed
by the inspector at the um the appeal
stage or otherwise in the case of
materials and they were included with
the application submission
so i think that's all i need to say at
this stage chair and obviously take some
questions
thank you very much open it up to
members first of all councillor mueller
then councillor mansell
thank you chair uh bradley in the papers
paragraph 5.7 you talk about triple
parking can you please let me know
please how many properties will have
triple parking on this site thank you
yes thank you councillor um i've got a
further plan which i didn't show in the
original
application submission which does deal
with that because i thought that that
may be something you would query um i
think we've calculated this 31 in total
and the developer
has actually indicated a plan showing
the provision of triple parking spaces
which as i've said in my report
are taken off of private drives rather
than the what would be the adoptable
highway network
sorry they're just for clarity they're
shown in pink
can you just elaborate on that for me so
so for example the bottom left hand one
you've got
uh you've got five houses all together
with triple parking
uh where do they park because they never
use triple parking so where will they
park their cars
if they have more than
because people don't triple park so
where are they supposed to park
i think that if the road is so narrow
there so they're going to block
the highway
well i think in this particular case
chair it would be
if you didn't park in these spaces you'd
be creating an obstruction for
other road users
so you know if you did have lots of cars
sitting up here you wouldn't physically
be able to to drive up and down there'd
be due to the nature of the road so i
think it would be neighborly if that's
the right word to use that triple
parking arrangement
okay so on the i on the i it's very hard
to see so on the on the other side of
that road what is that green verges or
is it
um on this particular part these would
be soft areas to the front yes so
they'll park on the soft areas
well there's nothing to stop them doing
that certainly
okay thank you
councilman
thank you chair um and uh thank you to
councillor muller because i too was
going to ask about triple parking uh but
my other um question relates to the
access for this site which
hasn't really gone into a lot of detail
in the presentation and i'd also like to
make reference to paragraph 5.4
which is on page 259.
now we've got a roundabout here
and in paragraph 5.4 it says it's
understand that the roundabout provides
a safe form of junction and it has
seemed to have done a safety audit
and then it goes on particularly bearing
in mind that this road also forms part
of national sustrans network
so we have
and it says that the junction includes
separate cyclist lanes which i couldn't
spot in the diagram
uh and i would like to know
bearing in mind that this is part of the
national cycle network route 51 what the
path of a cyclist traveling from ipswich
towards claydon
how they will
how they will go round the roundabout
because that cycle lane looks like it
forces you into the new housing estate
um yes
our apologies counselor man so i should
have um
dealt more time on the application in
terms of the my presentation in terms of
the access
this is the proposed form of access as
you can see hopefully which is showing
the the mini roundabout that would serve
the site um just by way of explanation
that would be the uh the root of the
cyclist it would be separate from the
the remainder of the carriageway
um because i think that the the actual
cycle route
starts or the defined cycle route starts
in that position at the present time and
continues up the road so what's been
designed is to include that round onto
the roundabout and then take it up
northwards
so that would be a a separate um
you know a separate provision for
cyclists just very quickly before um i
stopped these areas here just so members
are clear other crossing points on that
junction
can i come back to that so that cycle
lane
if you're coming northwards out of
ipswich
uh you are forced into the left-hand
uh lane so you it's really difficult to
go straight on um
and it is an on-road cycle path it is
not a dedicated off-road um separated
segregated cycle path
no the the the current provision on site
um is well the current provision in old
norwich road
for cyclists is within the carriageway
um and you come along here and there you
have the line where you meet the actual
roundabout so the cyclist if they wanted
to carry on north would be there at that
point and then cross the roundabout and
then go up yeah so in in entirely the
unsafe position but i will go into this
in debate
okay
count
councils
thank you yes i'm
grateful to see slide 47 i did ask the
officer to to make sure that was
included in the presentation and
thanks to councillor mansell for picking
up the same point
um
this the
i wondered on slide nine
there was a sort of black blob
um
which i didn't really understand
um
quite what that was what that was
telling us
um
and then when it i kind of disappeared
altogether when we got to the the the
layout of the houses
um
i suspect it's something to do with with
um
the um
drainage
or something
we not got back there yet have we um
oh yes that's it yes that's that council
yeah so what's yeah it's a bit yes it's
twisted round isn't it yeah so
yes so the the
yeah the orange blob
that was on the original on the earlier
map is turned into to a driveway
which is immediately above the black
blob
so what is the actual black blob
two blobs now do you mean that yeah yes
so yeah i think what's actually happened
when they produce this drawing they've
taken the layer or the photograph of the
the layout
and and
projected this over that photograph so
that is actually these existing trees
the line of existing trees on the site
and that's come through
the sort of the same color as the the
trees you've got along the top there
so that's trees
right yeah okay and then there's a path
through the middle of it somewhere
yes yes
light green blobs of the water new
planting then these are trees yes yeah
yeah okay thank you for that okay thank
you
okay we don't have any other hands up so
we'll now move on um
we don't have any
representative from the parish so i'll
now move to an objective wishes to speak
mr stephen bates if you'd like to turn
on your camera and your microphone
please
if we could take down the um slide
presentation please
okay
mr bates welcome
a good good afternoon now everybody uh
thank you very much for hearing me
um okay um are we already
okay have you got a camera you want to
turn on
hello have you have you got a camera you
would like to turn on
i have to turn that on it's come through
it's over to you you have three minutes
thank you very much uh good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen of the committee um
it seems like only yesterday that you
voted unanimously against this
development uh and if it matters to be
taken out of your hands at the appeal
while we must all accept the fact that
this development will progress we still
have the opportunity to ensure that it
is the best that it can be with this in
mind i come before you to raise the
serious concerns that the residents
still have
one there will be a considerable sub
system put in place on the southern
boundary of this site this is directly
above several low-lying properties on
old norwich road the residents of these
properties are extremely concerned about
the effect of the new subs development
on their properties in respect of
drainage and flooding should these plans
be passed in their current form what
guarantees will either mid suffolk
council or belway homes offer to the
residents of these properties in future
years
number two a buffer zone for this
development is being provided to the
northeast to which several of the new
properties rear gardens will back onto
previous experience tells us that these
can become a haven for fly-tipping
anti-social behavior another low-level
crime it was raised as a recommendation
by your own consultees that this
boundary should be brick wall rather
than wooden fencing to improve the
security of this boundary and stop new
residents erecting gated access into the
buffer zone i would urge the committee
to take note of your own council's
recommendations and compel their way
homes to erect a brick boundary to the
rear of these properties
number three the existing property to
the side of plot one is the bungalow
which already lies approximately two
meters lower than the new proposed
two-story building and is occupied by
two elderly residents aged 81 and 79.
not only will the new access road pass
directly to the side of their garden but
they will now be confronted with a
featureless two-story brick wall
directly behind their ear fence this
will will create a dominating and
overbearing presence as a retired couple
they spend a lot of time in their garden
and this building will destroy their way
of life and have a significant impact on
their mental health and well-being we
asked the committee to consider a
bungalow for this plot
number four we somewhat baffled by the
decision to build a roundabout as a site
access it appears to make no sense
whatsoever either in terms of road
safety cost or pollution as it stands
the northbound entrance to this
roundabout will service six houses and
two buses an hour hardly the typical
requirement for a roundabout
as you are aware the cameras at the bus
gate on old norwich road do not work and
an increasing number of residents of
clade and ipswich now use this with
impunity a roundabout would provide easy
access for residents of the new estate
to go northbound into claydon to avoid
congestion
furthermore as the proposal stand the
roundabout is cited directly on sole
access for stables
finally as noted above the residents
directly to the side of the site
entrance are quite elderly and with this
development scheduled to last
approximately five years that will
likely be the rest of their lives i
would therefore ask the committee to
ensure that a sympathetic management
plan is created and strictly enforced to
ensure the minimum noise impact possible
to residents thank you for your time
today and i welcome any questions you
may have thank you very much uh spot on
three minutes so thank you for that i'm
happy to open it up to questions could
you just just could you just from my
perspective on the um the brick boundary
wall you're talking about the acoustic
no no this is the gardens uh basically
um in the appeal decision um there was a
buffer zone um so this would be the
north east corner of the development
geographically um there's a boundary uh
buffer zone between the new estate and
existing houses on old norwich road
at the moment
belway proposed to put
wooden fencing in there i think your own
consultants suggested that should be a
brick wall but they appear to have
ignored that one
one assumes that's just cost
okay thank you very much
uh councillor field you have a question
i'm afraid um
uh you have a very high pitched voice
very fast
it's not the drum field we know
um
so john i i'm afraid um
what we're going to have to do is we're
going to have to just pause for you to
log out and log in again
was that the helium break counseling
yeah it wasn't it
well give him one minute you'll just log
in it's it
does happen every now and then
i don't want anyone else to ask
questions because otherwise he'd miss
hearing the answer so we just need to
wait for him to log back in okay i'm
back in i hope we're done john yep
you're back again
so welcome
thank you um i was just informing you
that my
surface pro is completely frozen i can't
even get the power to go off um so i
uh i left the meeting
about half past and i have just rejoined
i don't know whether the legal view is
then i shouldn't take any more notice
but uh
county council
did you hear what sorry is it is it mr
bell did i miss here is this speech
i do beg your pardon mr bates uh okay
i've heard nothing since the um uh the
sort of first question also to the to
the officer
council manager he's missed over he's
missed 10 minutes over 10 minutes
completely missed mr mr bates then yeah
right that's quite an issue isn't it um
uh well that it's not really not fair to
ask mr bates to repeat himself or two
and also he and he's missed more than
that because mr bates only spoke for
three minutes and he's missed ten
minutes
um well
so he's his counselor
field is the county councillor for the
area he's not the war he's not the
district member is he no
otherwise he wouldn't be voting anyway
i yeah i hate to say this i think we're
going to have to lose councillor feel
from the rest of this item
i can't mr carmichael unless you can
think of
an option that avoids that which i can't
um
yeah i mean unless we redo the last 10
12 minutes
i would tend to agree share with my
colleague mr duprey and i
apologize on that point but it's um it
is um
as per regulatory meetings that all
information must be heard for a
counselor to make a decision and vote on
it
i'll uh i'll listen with interest and uh
not vote thank you
okay councillor matheson you're ready
yeah yeah i was just wondering whether
we might have the option of of hearing
council of field but not letting him
vote you probably have useful things to
say no well no we we need to if he's not
participating he's not participating
he's all or nothing i think yeah
sorry
uh count
uh okay cancer maths anything else no
okay thank you very much for that mr
bates we'll now move on to the agent
laura dudley smith
and uh sarah cornwell who's also here to
answer questions
if you'd like to turn your camera on
please and again you have three minutes
good morning just checking you can all
hear and see me
yeah we can
yeah
thank you good afternoon members thank
you for the opportunity to participate
in today's development control committee
meeting i'm laura dudley smith of
strassen parker strassen parker the
planning consultants acting on behalf of
bellway homes for the scheme presented
this afternoon
beltware homes are a successful house
builder delivering and building out a
number of sites across suffolk in essex
you will be aware of the recent consent
granted to 65 homes in hawley which
gives an indication of belway's
commitment to high quality design and
layout as well as that also recently
approved 75 homes in worsted by the
labour planning committee
outline planning permission on this
application site was granted on appeal
in march 2019 the principle of access
from old norwich road was agreed through
the outline permission and this
application deals with its details
alongside layout scale appearance and
landscaping having regard to the
requirements of the parameters of the
plans also previously agreed
the plans before you have developed as a
result of close working with the
council's offices and console teas as
the officers have indicated the scale
layout and appearance of the proposed
development has been carefully
considered to take account of a number
of existing site constraints and
features including noise overhead cables
trees and utility easements whilst also
meeting the council's design standards
it has been important to ensure that
there will be no adverse impact upon
existing residential properties adjacent
to the site as a result the plans
provide a landscaping buffer with
appropriate boundary treatments to
ensure ensure security to the rear of
these properties in this area in
particular all the homes will meet
nationally described space standards and
will also provide ducting for electric
vehicle charging
we have worked with suffolk county
highways to ensure that the site's
access meets the county's standards in
terms of dimensions and safety alongside
the internal road networking parking
provision too the proposed roundabout
arrangement has been requested by
suffolk highways in the interests of
usability and safety for all users and
has also been the subject of a stage two
safety audit further assurances
there are no objections from the
council's housing officer nor from
ecology landscape drainage or
environmental health consultants
specifically we have worked with the
suffolk county council's archaeology
team to agree an appropriate
investigation strategy for the site too
and have also engaged directly with
neighbouring residents and the parish
council throughout the planning process
we believe any outstanding queries in
this regard have been covered in the
offices report the development of the
site will ensure the provision of the
section 106 contributions that were
agreed to outline of over a million
pounds towards a new primary school
highways improvements and the council's
rams as well as nearly 2 million pounds
of sale payments to assist the council's
wider infrastructure needs for the
district also the site will provide 67
affordable homes and a large area of
landscaped open space which will include
a young children's play area we do hope
that you'll be able to agree with your
office's recommendation to ensure the
delivery of this site and the provision
of new homes to meet the needs of the
local area alongside the other
associated benefits thank you very much
for your time
thank you very much okay questions um
i've i haven't got any oh council
council stringer then councilman so then
i'm coming after them
thank you chair a couple of questions uh
you said you're only going to be putting
ducting in for electric charging
and the cabling and then cables are kind
of rolled up and put behind a plate
basically so it's the only the only bit
that would need to be installed would be
the specific actual kind of boxes that
will
will vary obviously between different
requirements and use preferences so so
it's the ducting and the cabling that is
being provided also how are these
dwellings going to be heated
um
i think that's due to be covered in the
sustainability
information that's been requested by
condition um so that's been applied to
the outline that was applied to the
outline consent um i don't know i've got
i think we've got sarah on the call from
belway um homes whether she's got any um
intentions in this regard at this stage
uh yes you're correct laura that this
will be um uh sorted out at the rm stage
um
for the conditions uh we've got a new
condition for stability we'll address it
in there but uh basically yeah it
probably will be gas boilers which
ordinarily it is
uh
sorry it isn't
okay uh it it it makes a difference to
the sustainability financially of the
dwellings if you're going to use fossil
fuel because they're being phased out
and mortgage companies are getting
increasingly concerned now about
mortgaging gas-fired buildings
so i understand that the um the eha that
we've been using with regarding the um
who's requested for the application of
this additional condition to the uh to
any rm approval um does specifically
require details of projected costs for
future upgrades and elements to be so
that he can consider them in respect of
discharging that condition
so hopefully that would enable you know
him them to have the you know
that at that point and for discussions
as required to before any condition can
be discharged
counselor mansell
uh thank you chair um just i did have a
couple of questions of my own but just
following on from the um conversation
following council stringer's question
i'm a little confused because the um
presenters are talking about the rm
application i thought this was the
reserve matters application so i'm a
little bit confused about that but my i
have i have um a couple of questions
one is to do with uh one of the plans
that we've got in the
on the on the website is a chimney plan
uh and there are a number of houses that
allocate seem to have a chimney is that
are they actually gonna have a fireplace
or are these just sort of cosmetic
chimneys and i would like to go back to
the access arrangements and i i don't
know if we still have our suffolk
council highways person here um but can
you tell me if other access arrangements
were considered or whether it just went
straight to being a roundabout
um so if i jump in there initially um
the
chimneys yes i think they're primarily
aesthetic features um they were
something that were added during the
lifetime of the application um following
discussion with the planning officers
who requested these as kind of
additional design features and to
provide variation across the site um and
in terms of the access uh
agree happy i'm happy for input from
suffolk highways and say if they are
already here but our understanding is
that well we know that um yes a number
of options were considered including
kind of more standard priority junctions
but the
in a lot of instances whilst one would
favor
one user um it would be to the detriment
of others and i think that was um hence
why suffolk's conclusion was that
actually this felt like the best kind of
all-round solution and to ensure um
safety for all users of the access
okay thank you counselor mathson
thank you chair yes uh
on going on on very much the same
grounds as
council stringer has started page 319 of
our papers we've got the um
environmental management
um
officer asking
in fact pointing out that the the
condition that was was requested in 2017
um
that's presumably that was a we've
refused eventually i think and then it
was appealed um
that the
the request for a sustainability and
energy strategy at that time has still
not been met
um
at this time
and bearing in mind the point just made
about um we really don't want any more
gas-fired heating
excuse me the um have have the
architects not
considered the orientation of the
dwellings in order to minimize the
requirement for for heating
to be provided
um so i think
you're right so in terms of the
environmental health comments um you
rightly recognize that i think they
requested a condition to be applied to
the outlying consent that wasn't applied
and therefore we had no reason to there
was no condition for us to discharge at
that point hence why they're now
requesting that um a similar or similar
condition is required to any approval of
this result of a reserve matters
application um so that it remains uh
a topic still for discussion and for
approval by the eho and the local
planning authority um so that's the
current position on that and i think in
terms of orientation of the the
buildings um
obviously i think
from an architectural perspective i
would expect that for our architects
that's a sort fundamental fundamental
principle of design that's followed on
all schemes like this um and it would
have been taken into account as far as
is um sort of feasible and achievable on
the site
so really we're not being we're not
being offered any any um
indication of how the heating is going
to take place either than connecting it
to the gas grid we haven't actually got
any any
tangible evidence in front of us at the
moment
i say my understanding is at the moment
it would be the baseline would be for it
to be gas that's um provided across um
railway schemes as standard but
obviously that is going to be further
open to further discussion with the
planning authority environmental health
team as part of the
agreement of the proposed condition
could we hear from belleway on that
point here
by all means
yeah um
uh we we normally build houses with gas
boilers is what it comes down to however
there is this the condition that we need
to meet um i'm not sure there's anything
within your policy that says that it
needs to be any other way of heating a
house uh it's very unusual for a
condition to be placed on us that we
need to be doing a different uh
heat source um
unfortunately you know residents of
future residents aren't um aren't as
amicable to to new ways of heating their
properties they're used to gas boilers
that's what when they see they know how
to use them
um anything else is just it's obviously
is not marketable
for us
but obviously if if this condition needs
to be approved uh by your stability
officer there's a different situation
but
thank you chair thank you
council stringer you want to come back
and i'll come in after you
yeah i just just want to uh just clarify
a few issues in terms of gas being
normal
we are in mid-suffolk
gas connection is actually the abnormal
here
and equally government is outlawing
fossil fuel boilers and the time is
varying but the time for banning them
will be in the mortgageable life of
these properties
and that's why the sustainability
argument economically comes in
if there isn't a uh ecologically
uh
minded approach to how we develop
just because we've always done it
no longer cuts it in terms of those that
will be asked to fund these properties
i.e mortgage companies so what we're
tasked with doing is making sure that
builders don't build things that then
become economically unsustainable
yeah so um again just jumping quickly i
think
thank you for the comments it's all
noted um
fundamentally how a property is
heated um is not to my understanding a
kind of
material consideration for the for
consideration of a reserve matters
application hence why um our expectation
is it's something that would be dealt
with by way of condition and a technical
delivery stage
okay can i just ask a quick couple of
questions um would you would the app can
be able to comment around the question
around the brick wall that was mentioned
by the mr bates
and also around changing the design next
to the bungalow so the bungalow isn't
overshadowed
and finally the triple parking uh we
know triple parking doesn't work it
causes chaos on estates i see the
sarah corwell's nodding to that so you
know only too well that it doesn't work
and it obviously doesn't work on beltway
uh projects either so what can we do to
overcome the 31
houses that have got triple parking that
we know will cause chaos with people
parking on verges
um okay dealing with the triple parking
first thing um i don't believe it will
create chaos um i think that the
position of the triple parking is in
private drives
um
you're saying that they could
potentially park on verge they can't
because that's going to be their front
garden and they're probably going to
have either a brick wall or some sort of
fencing or a nice hedge along there i
don't think they're going to be parked
on the um
the front of their garden at all they're
going to have free spaces um which is
adequate for them to park in is is what
i feel i wouldn't be you know we have to
manage these schemes we're a management
company they'll be um owned the
management company until it gets passed
on to a separate management company
we don't want to give ourselves a
headache um we feel that in this
location it is fine um because otherwise
it is because we we're just going to be
having residents just raising issues
within a management company constantly
and that's something that we obviously
want to avoid so
we feel at this location it's it's fine
okay well that'll be for us i guess to
decide and the brick boundary the brick
boundary um i think i know what he's
talking about um to be honest with you i
don't know the exact detail of where it
whether it's all of faith or whether
it's all a brick wall
um
i don't think there's an issue with the
uh
the buffer zone being
uh
uh you know undue
security or anything along there we've
fenced it off there's a gate for just a
management company to
maintain the area uh we did originally
leave it open so that the residents
could use it but with in um in
discussions with mr banks we've closed
it off
um and it just will literally be for the
management company uh to maintain it uh
cut the grass pruning the trees we put
some trees in there as well to kind of
block some views um if it's if it is a
really big issue i'm sure we can put
some brick walls down there i don't see
the point personally because it's a far
enough buffer area
away from their properties i don't think
it would have a an impact whether
there's a there's a fence or a wall it
is a boundary um but if it is a major
point then i'm sure we could accommodate
that
and the house next to the bungalow
the elderly people in their 70s and 80s
yeah
um we have changed the orientation of
plot one um
we have changed the orientation of the
uh the roof line um we have made sure
that the window has got um obscure laser
in it we've moved it as far away as we
can from the plot
um from his existing housing
bungalow
it is a sales area it won't be occupied
for some time because it will be um it
won't be in use until the uh the the
south and pretty much the whole
development has been um sold and then it
will be sold off so if he's talking i
don't put um a times go on it but
realistically it's not going to be in
use for a good sort of three four years
anyway it's good it is a sales office in
the southeast so people i don't get that
i don't get the relevance of that
well he's saying that it's um
people are going to be in there and um
affecting his amenity
for that bungalow plot however no one's
actually going to be living there until
right at the end of the development
because it is a sales unit so people
will be wandering around having a look
at the unit but no one's going to be in
the garden playing football right but
your houses lost
yeah okay yeah i mean
it gets sold off at the end of the of
the whole scheme yeah someone's gonna be
in there for a while
yeah so what you're saying is you don't
think it's gonna impact them for three
years but in three years it will impact
yeah or maybe even longer than that by
the time they build up these games again
okay councilor mayor
thanks chet um
looking at the position of the suds the
point made by um mr bates
that
the existing housing is downhill from
the the large um
subs area is there any scope from moving
that elsewhere on that plot so that
should that suds fail in some way the
water isn't gonna fall downhill into
their garden house
so the the location and the depth and
the size of that has all been all takes
into account obviously the site levels
um and the way the site drains obviously
you can't just put a sud space in
anywhere on the site because the water
wouldn't travel to it um so it has to be
at the point at which the water is
expected to to root through to um and
that has been deemed to be that location
um
it would you know
it would feel therefore that presumably
if there's you know that location has
been agreed um with the drainage
engineers and um
suffolk esophagus the lead local flood
flood authority that the water will be
routed to that location it would be
unlikely for it to go back on itself
back towards the houses um
i don't you know we have to take the
advice of our drainage consultants and
suffolk county as the flood authority
for in that respect that this is the
suitable location and it's been
designed to what's considered
appropriate and safe for both new and
existing users
okay thank you
thank you very much
right we move on so
we have no other speakers questions so
we now move on to the ward members we
have two board members councillor tim
passmore and councillor john whitehead
who would like to go first
if you want to take it off better
clinton let him go first okay cancer
pass more
tim pass casper pasmo do you want to go
first
my mistake thank you very much for
reminding me i was getting straight in
there before i was quite ready
getting ahead of myself um now i just
really want to emphasize the points that
tom stephen bates made very very well
indeed and i absolutely support all of
those now i don't know if the committee
is able to look at this in some detail
and make sure that the conditions deal
with this um well i think we heard from
sarah regarding the the brick wall
and security and these sorts of things
it's really important we don't have
pockets for anti-social behavior and
other things that happen i would just
say you can of course get advice from
designing out crime officers from that
well-known organization the suffolk
constabulary and it is important for
that as well of course as fly tipping um
so i hope the management company uh
bearing in mind obviously outline
permissions already been given that is a
serious point so just ask the the
committee to remember that uh also on
this point about the plot number one i
think what we were really getting at
there
is that by putting a show house there i
understand there needs to be one there
but i think what was really awesome is
there any way that that plot number one
could actually be a bungalow instead and
i think if you want to work with people
locally that would be really really
appreciated and i'm sure john whitehead
will be able to clarify a little bit
more on that um if necessary um the
drainage and the flooding um we have to
take obviously the drainage engineers
word for that all i would ask is in
these days of rather extreme weather
events
please make sure we are dealing for the
unexpected once in a hundred year
um event so
bigger pipes bigger drainage scheme with
the capacity far better to do it now
than wait till oh dear there's a problem
and then we end up in a complete muddle
and i'm afraid um
chairman i'm going to come back to this
business about the um the junction and
highways which he had a protracted
discussion about in the previous
application
we really really do need to make sure
that it's safe for cyclists i know it's
a very quiet part of the old a45 but
with this big development there that
will change and the real concern from a
lot of people
discussed at the clayton parish council
meeting on uh monday evening
was will people be tempted to try and
use the old a45 to get to the a14 which
of course shouldn't be permitted
and i know it's not the um applicant's
job to make sure that the cctv there is
working absolutely get that but the
reality is we need to make sure that
people are going in the right way the
permitted way and which of course is
back towards it rather than trying to
take a shortcut which is prohibited so i
would ask the committee and perhaps the
planning officers if there is a way they
could look at that to make sure that
those concerns which are all legitimate
from the parish council local people are
addressed just remind you that the
parish council's comments are there um
on page 271 oh and the last comment i
want to make on the parking
really have to make sure that works well
don't forget we did have problems those
of us who've been on the council for
some time many years ago in parts of the
cedars park development when there was a
i think we had one and a half parking
place per house
it caused some chaos but it also
restricted the access for example of
refuge collections and emergency service
vehicles so just need some reassurance
um that that will not become a problem
because that would be pretty disastrous
for all of us so we'll now hand over to
my colleague john whitehead if that's
okay chairman thank you
much your handguard so bring you in
mayor sorry very
after after after the other local member
if that's right sorry
okay thank you
councilwoman hello can you hear and see
me
yes
all right good afternoon members
as well as being the ward member for
clayton and barham ward i'm also a
parish councillor on the claim and
whitney parish council and those parish
councillors are happy for me to speak on
their behalf today whilst i'm wearing my
ward member hat so that's why you
haven't heard from the parish council
separately
you have of course already seen their
written representations within the
committee documentation
but there really isn't a great deal
extra that either myself or the parish
council could wish to add beyond what's
already been eloquently presented to you
by mr bates who has spoken today as an
objector
mr bates as a resident whose home is
adjacent to development undertook the
role of spokesperson for his near
neighbors with both rigor and passion
throughout the original application
process which even included addressing
the inspector at the appeal hearing but
i welcome the opportunity to reinforce
my own words the points that mr bates
has raised so that it will be fresh in
your minds as we go into debate
so turn into those concerns
we were all surprised to see a proposed
roundabout at the entrance to this site
the old norwich road to the north of it
is closed to all but buses and cycles
within a short distance
it serves only a half a dozen houses
plus those occasional buses and cycles
therefore the new road into the new
estate of 190 dwellings will clearly
become the main road with a high level
of vehicle movements
like you i've read in the report pack
the reasons made by highways for a
roundabout
and whilst they are obviously experts in
this field it still doesn't intuitively
feel like it is the correct decision
unless there is some hidden agenda for
the future surely been more sensible to
curve the new road into the new estate
with just a minor junction of it to the
right when approaching from ipswich a
minor junction just to serve the few
existing houses on the old road
and on that old road beyond this
proposed roundabout there is immediately
the cell access to stables on the right
plus a private drive within a few meters
serving two existing dwellings on the
left
how odd then
to have a straight how how odd for those
to be straight off a fast flowing
roundabout
local residents here as well as those in
clayton village want the old norwich
road to remain closed to through traffic
and that's a message i've heard
constantly and clearly over the last 10
years
with the present inadequate in-ground
barrier and unmanned unmanned cctv
cameras
more and more drivers unfortunately do
break the law and travel through the
no-go zone
money from this new development must go
towards beefing up the barriers and are
monitoring the illegal road use
many new residents with children
attending the local schools in claydon
will also be tempted to use this
unauthorized route
as mr bates has already told you a
roundabout here will simply encourage
rather than deter usage
now as the plans are currently drawn my
heart goes out to the elderly residents
george and lorna who live in the
existing bungalow adjacent to the post
house on plot one
the officer in his presentation has
already mentioned the adverse height
changes from east to west
and i have visited myself and seen
firsthand their home and garden
standing there it's easy to envisage the
two-story sidewall of plot one to the
west south west
and understand how it would block both
the afternoon sun for most of the year
as well as being an unpleasant of true
unpleasantly obtrusive at all other
times it may be maybe too big an ask of
the developers for a bungalow to be
built on plot one as we're told today
that plots one and two will be used as
marketing show homes
but showed if the plans were just
changed marginally so that on entering
the new development there would be first
a single garage
and then the detached house then another
single garage and then another detached
house
that could be a reasonable compromise
which would significantly ameliorate the
situation
i mean i can understand why it's planned
as it is putting a double garage between
plots one and two may form a useful
short-term office and marketing suite
for the show home staff
but the effect this marginally
short-term benefit is achieved only at
the expense of the long term detriment
to the existing neighbors
and finally just to cover two other
points quickly
there is a match with the boundary fence
onto the northeast buffer zone you've
heard of as cons as consultees have
recommended that should be a brick wall
to improve security and prevent any
access for flight tipping antisocial
behavior
there's also a real concern over the
proposed suds on nearby residents whose
homes already sit on a high water table
and who fear more flooding
belway and their agents have certainly
done some excellent work both with
planning officers and in consulting with
existing residents whilst drawing up
these proposals
it's a shame that that good work has
been let down by the key issues we've
highlighted today
issues with the roundabout with plot one
the lack of a brick wall with the suds i
i do feel these issues really need to be
fundamentally addressed as part of this
applications determination thank you
very much
very much do you have any questions for
the board members please
okay so we'll now move in to we don't uh
have anyone else that wishes to speak
therefore now go into open debate
and please just raise your hands as
normal
and
make a start
wants to go first
counselor
thank you chair no i fully agree with
what mr bates and also the ward members
have actually said about plot one um
it's okay to say well it's going to be a
show home in its current form it won't
be occupied for three or four years but
at the end of the day it will be
occupied and it could seriously affect
the immunity of the elderly couple
living on the original
bungalow
secondly i still have grave concerns
about the triple parking members
remember we had a case in badwa lash a
few weeks ago
where we we deferred the application
because of the uh triple parking and the
um applicant came back with a new
proposal which was acceptable
um both uh councillor parcel has raised
this cashler hicks as the chair has
raised this i live on cedars park there
is triple parking and i can assure
members it's an absolute nightmare
and i'm pretty convinced certainly from
what i have seen around stone market
particularly on cedars park that people
will park on soft forages rather than
using the actual triple parking thank
you chair that's what i wish to say
thank you very much councillor mansell
uh thank you chair um i am
there are a lot of things about this
development that i i really don't like
one of which is false chimneys uh i
really don't see the point of putting
fake chimneys on a roof um when they
serve no purpose um and i'm sure there
are other ways of making houses slightly
more distinctive
but i think that is a minor issue
compared with some of the other issues
um
i'm not happy that they're likely to be
gas-fired heating
i'm sure others on this committee will
have more to say about that
but the thing that i am completely uh
goes completely against my thoughts is
this roundabout um as the junction
to access this development i'm in
complete agreement with councillor
whitehead's comment is i don't
understand why they didn't curve the
right-of-way around into the development
because this large development is what
is going to be causing all the traffic
on old norwich road
i'm familiar with the bike path i used
to live um
in ipswi on that side of ipswich uh and
i think the issues with the uh bus gate
are
a long-standing and and people do use it
as a cut-through but considering this is
on part of national cycle network
um and we should be doing especially in
the current climate we should be doing
all that we can to encourage people to
be out on their bikes to get between
this development ipswich and clayton
this is on a cycle path and yet the
cycle provision at the roundabout is
appalling um
unfortunately uh on-road cycle lanes
force people four cyclists onto the
left-hand side of the road and if they
want to go straight on which is the way
the cyclists are going to go on this
bike route they are in completely the
wrong position on a roundabout is unsafe
for them so either we need to completely
change the layout of that roundabout or
we need to have a proper off-road cycle
path because this is part of the
national cycle network um i i i assume
that mr barber is no longer with us but
i would love to hear suffolk county
council's um reasons as to why they
thought this was the most appropriate
access arrangement
uh one other thing i don't like about
this development is the fact that it
doesn't seem to have taken any
opportunity
um to improve pedestrian connectivity um
in a way it almost looks like a bit of a
sort of old-fashioned estate where we're
trying to block people off force them
into their cars um and and not encourage
people to walk
um having um landscape buffers that just
seem like complete dead ends and a waste
of space
why weren't they turned into some sort
of uh feature um and pedestrian access
way
and have houses looking onto it or
whatever to solve the crime issue
um i just don't think the layout is fit
for the 21st century
so unless i hear
other comments that make me change my
mind i do not feel that i'm in a
position that i can support this
application
thank you very much councilman
yes uh unfortunately it does look as if
the committee is going to need to do its
its job as it has quite a few times over
the last couple of years
um of um asking the the applicant to to
go away and come up with something
improved um we've been pretty successful
at that
we do get the improvements thankfully
and um i you know i think it's
it's unfortunate that bellway have not
not perhaps been in front of the
committee um in recent times in
mid-suffolk
to to know that we we were not happy
with gas any longer and that we've got
to sustain you know we've got a climate
uh um emergency declared and so on and
so on so i think that we're going to be
spending the next few minutes and and
council manchester's got off to a very
good start
in explaining the various things that do
need improving and certainly uh with her
the
the roundabout junction and the cycling
is not not good and i i would suggest
that given given the volume of traffic
um into ipswich into ipswich that the
sus trains have got new criteria for for
um
for designating and i fear that this
section between this development and
into ipswich on road on road uh will be
de-designated for the for the volume of
traffic which would which would be very
sad to see but that's where it would go
um and the
the real way forward in terms of heating
is to minimize the need through
orientation and i'd refer
um
the the
representatives of belway and agents to
actually look at and see the national
planning policy framework
148 150 and 153
in particular thank you chair
thank you um i was going to speak after
uh after councillor mansell but i didn't
say if i can come in now i would like to
propose that we uh defer this
application
um i think for many reasons it doesn't
meet the high standards that we expect
in mid-suffolk
um i think the triple parking it was
raised with bellway before today but
they thought they'd come along and see
what we'd say
we made it clear through officers that
we don't like triple parking on this
scale
to me it's not an acceptable layout um
it's not acceptable in terms of immunity
to the bungalow um i think to say for
belleway to say was only a problem for
it won't be a problem for three until
three years time it's just not an
acceptable approach uh we need to think
about what's best permanently not what
happens in three years time so i would
ask that bill we need to think about the
amenity to the neighbor and i think the
points around the brick wall and the
suds need further thought uh so for me
um i accept something that's going to
happen on this side but i think this is
this is a a poorly conceived
plan that hasn't been thought through in
enough detail and to me i certainly
wouldn't be supported and i would
suggest we defer it and ask the
applicant to go away and give it more
thought and come back on another
occasion can i second that chair
yeah of course you can council matheson
thank you but obviously we have more
speakers uh counselor mayor you're next
thanks chair um yes i'd echo everything
you've said um i am particularly
concerned about the studs area i do not
see why you have to bring all of the
drainage water across the
the open ground to put it into a storage
pond that sits directly behind an uphill
to existing properties
though the cynic in me says well it does
keep the open area open and who knows
what can be developed there in the
future
um
i'd also question this um buffer area
i'm not sure putting a brick wall in
would work and when i was a kid you put
a brick wall in the only thing that gets
bounced off is a football and so you're
creating other problems um for me i
don't understand why we need the buffer
area i'd just extend the gardens or
indeed as i think it was councillor
mansell suggested provide pedestrian
access to the eastern end of the site um
so yes i'm i'll be happily supporting
the recommendation to
send this back for another look thank
you
thank you um
council amounts was that an old hand
it's an old handsome yeah i'm sorry we
don't allow the applicant or the agent
to come back in
bradley would you like to comment before
i go to counselor muller
yes thank you chad i think there's
various points that i've picked up from
the debate and i understand
the reasoning behind them i think it's
worth pointing out or just reminding
members that
this this reserve matters application
does have with within it or sorry is
guided
to a significant extent by the
parameters plan
and i think in terms of the importance
that is attached to that
there there are you know elements of
that that i think it was an intention of
the inspector that they should be set as
part of the um
the reserve matters proposal
um and things such as um the buffer zone
and things like that were specifically
identified within that plan to be
provided and in fairness to the
applicant i think that they've reflected
that in their drawing so
the other thing i would like to say is
um with regard to the overall layout um
in my view
when planning view is a responsive uh
layout in terms of the way that the site
works um it uses the site in order to
get the permitted number of
dwellings on there in a
you know in a in a location and a
position that creates
space creates streets um does have
permeability and
in our view and does um really suit that
particular site and it's not something
that's been brought to you without those
particular points being considered at
some length so we are quite happy with
that
we did have a look at the issue with
regard to the amenity impact
and i understand fully the point that's
being made but if you look at the
position of the house in relation to the
boundary
excuse me and and the way that
new development generally butts up to
existing dwellings
in truth there wasn't really anything we
felt that could compel the developer to
do anything else in relation to
if they wanted to position a house in
there on that layout in order to
you know
protect the impact more than they have
done so i think that again that's fair
to say
um
the suds in truth we've been guided by
the lead local
flood
authority um that whole system has been
agreed through significant discussion
with them the location of the suds um
is within the open space primarily i i
would think because a it works in
relation to site topography
and b if you put a lot of suds areas
within the area zone for residential
development that obviously then impacts
on the the layout in terms of the
numbers that have been approved on this
particular site and lastly with regard
to the the roundabout i think it's fair
to again reiterate that that
approach has been taken there the
developer has been guided in that
approach by the highway authority i
don't think it's something that they
necessarily suggested off their own
heads i think they've been guided
specifically to come up with that design
and that approach as it was felt to be
most appropriate to serve that
development in that location thank
what about the you parking because
you've had conversations with them about
the triple parking
yes and um i'm reminded by councillor um
councillor muller identified
i was the officer who brought the uh the
job at uh bad will ash to you i know
that it's not popular with um committee
um and the only thing i can say is that
that concern is not shared by the
highway authority in fact they
specifically identified in their
consultation response that they're
comfortable with that approach so if
members aren't happy with that as a
principle
then um you know i'm i'm i'm thinking
that there's limited
influence we can have if the highway
authority are advising us that that
arrangement in those particular
locations works
thank you
councillor then councillor
uh thank you chair i must admit i do
agree from what you said chair
previously that i still think we need to
defer this this particular claim for
further thought to be put into it and i
totally respect what bradley has just
just said but it's quite clear that
members aren't happy with this current
application so i think deferment is is
the best option and refer back to
committee at a later stage thank you
chair
yeah thanks matthew it's just i know
this i'm not going to vote on this award
member just to say look i think there
are grounds there to get this put right
so it is about working together and so
on and i'm sure i'm sorry tim i can't
bring you in again i'm sorry i forgot
over the world but you've already spoken
all right
anyway
uh thank you chair for allowing me to
come back i was just going to say if we
are going to be deferring this which it
looks like we're going to go go to a
vote on that shortly um
will are we in any position to ask
highways for more input about the
roundabout decision and about the
acceptability or unacceptability of
triple parking
uh if we do if it does come back to
committee
would it help if i stepped in their
chair
so i was just gonna say i've i've tried
to make notes of the points members have
raised uh in terms of a possible
deferral so if i quickly run through
those so we're looking at the triple
parking provision the boundary treatment
to the buffer area the design of plot
one and then to respond to council
mansell's question the roundabout
including the cycle route
the false chimneys the heating
pedestrian connectivity and suds details
i hope that's covered everything but
please do tell me if that is too much or
too little
okay
i'm muted as well okay i'm sorry your um
chair's sound quality is very scratchy
at the moment i'm not hearing it very
well
um
i just said are you happy with those
points as a seconder
yeah i i am actually yes thank you
chairman walker counselor yeah all i
wanted to add really was to the you know
the bradley's um
reasonable points that that um
oh well the highways and the triple
parking i think if we were talking about
a handful of triple parking situations
well that would be one thing but i think
that 31
homes with triple parking is is a huge
number
and um and we know that chaos will
ensure
and i think that for me the biggest
headache was there were six houses all
next to each other all with triple
parking if there was one dotted
occasionally around you would cope but
there were six all together on one uh
side street so councillor field over to
you thank you and well i'm
sort of partly in limbo on this one
missing bit but i was just going to
point out the council of whitehead did
mention the um
the possibility of improvements to the
bus gate at the moment
part of the um
the way the road uh junction is
orientated is dependent on um the the
old road remaining closed and that bus
gate i certainly as a county council get
persistent complaints about vehicles
transiting across it
including complaints from the people who
damage their vehicles so doing but um
if anything could be added to say that
we should get highways or someone to
commit to uh some improvements there
that would i think um be of benefit
thank you thank you okay
sorry check it or just just uh um advise
or
give further advice on that point when
the application went to
um committee and appeal um
it was for the larger site as i advised
before which was for
315 i think it was units
at that time the section 106
was including improvements to the bus
gate
but
in
providing a split decision on the
application the inspector specifically
identified that because there was a
lesser number of units he didn't
identify that as one of the elements
that could be secured through the
section 106 agreement so the section 106
agreement as listed in my report
those elements are secured on as a
result the development on this
particular site so i don't think we
could actually reasonably seek in my
view that we could get further
improvements the bus gate on the back of
this through legal agreement or other
means because i think that's already
been tested yeah thanks but i was just
gonna say i would i would have concern
about us doing that i think that
clarifies the the issues behind it yeah
okay
thank you very much so we're gonna go to
a vote now uh so gemma has run through
all the reasons on why we think this
should be deferred and we would ask that
the app can go away and give that some
thought and please bring it back to us
uh the sooner the better we'd like to
have the application before us again
with um with some further thought going
into it so all those in favor of
deferral we'll now have to go to the
electronic vote and i'll hand over to
robert carmichael
to put all that text in
to
the voter
i think
hopefully that
has
just got to wait for it to update
no that hasn't worked sorry apologies
chair i will be
one i'm just sorting this out
sorry here's what happens when we give
you last minute things to put into the
vote
the right chair is
part of democracy so it's uh
it's what i'm here to do but it's just
the new system
obviously to so that in one sense it
benefits that we can all see
um
the vote as it happens
okay
nearly there chair
from
okay
right on the last one now chair
it's just got to
right
right members that should now appear
green sorry light blue in the modern.gov
voting app ready for members to vote
i would know that obviously council
passed more
cannot vote on this one no as the uh
board member
and nor control councillor field i'm
afraid no
right i have all votes now apart from
councillor matheson and councillor
oh no
that's
well everyone cheer it's just slow yep
sorry counselor matheson that's now come
through so i'll now stop the vote
so that was unanimously four chair by
six votes
okay thank you very much
now members um are we happy to do one
more before lunch or do you want to have
lunch a 15-minute lunch i'm i'm in your
hands
i'd certainly like a comfort break
please
okay let's can we do lunch in 20 minutes
any objection
okay so can we start at five to two
literally 20 minutes
yeah um okay
see you in 20 minutes
good afternoon and welcome back to
mid-south district council development
control committee a so we now move on to
the next item on the agenda
which is uh dc 2004 296 stone and barnes
donna massable and now invite the case
officer braun curtis to introduce the
application to committee
over to you
thank you chair good afternoon all just
share the presentation
so the application is a full application
at the stone and barnes leisure and
tourism complex which is located in the
countryside between the villages of
stoner massable and peta
the proposal is for the sighting of an
additional 18
caravans
at the fishing lakes part of the complex
as an extension to the existing
um
arrangement of caravans that are used
for holiday accommodation at that part
of the complex
if i run you through the slides
you can see
the area
for the 18 additional caravans on this
aerial view
with the main part of the complex over
towards the left of this slide
that is the same thing on ordnance base
so you can see a little bit more clearly
where the
villages and surrounding properties are
this shows um
where the additional 18 caravans are
proposed to be cited in relation to to
some of the existing development this
plan is not uh it doesn't show
everything that's since been permitted
there's been uh five caravans permitted
in more or less the center of
this slide where my cursor is which i'll
show you in a moment
and there have been caravans permitted
which are
on site in this area here
so this is the proposed layout with the
additional caravans shown in blue
in
the right hand corner there
and this slide is showing the additional
five units that were granted permission
by committee last august
if i flick backwards you can just see
the change in arrangement in that top
corner
and then photographs showing the end of
the complex as it exists at the moment
so we're looking um towards peta
across the agricultural land which forms
the
the edge of the complex in this
direction
and then these photographs turn around
so this view is looking up towards the
a1120 highway
you can see in this center far
background a white building that's
wayside cottage which sits on the
highway and then these following
pictures just turn round
to the east and then south
so turning further east
turning further south and then turning
back round
so you can see the land from within the
site looking back towards the existing
complex and you can see the sort of
structure that we're we're considering
here with the caravan units
you can see some of the landscape
planting that's already taken place
for some of the previous development
that's these little
white strips which are whipped plants
and then this is taken from slightly
further back just showing one of the um
drainage ditches on the southern
boundary of the site and looking back in
the background there towards the complex
of existing caravans
excuse me and then i've got some
landscape views from the highway
so this is taken hard on the highway
actually um looking south towards the
complex
so you can see the
top of the existing complex around the
fishing lakes area on the right hand
side and then in the far background you
can see
the
southern portion of the caravan complex
and then you can see the application
site so the additional caravans going in
this area over here
that's another landscape shot just to
give you the context and an appreciation
of the
views from the highway
similar
this is an image that i took from
another application
from the site just so that you've got
the contrast of the
highway
vegetation in
a different season
so you can see there's gaps at this sort
of time of year
but the vegetation comes into fuller
leaf
later
um
the
application has had some objections
excuse me i'm just going to grab a drink
the application has had some objections
from
um
parish councils
both petra and stoner masspel have
raised concerns
particularly about the
creep of the development of the whole
complex into the open landscape and into
the countryside in general
also some concerns about the capacity of
the complex to support any additional
development
and the impact that that might have on
the surrounding area
and there has also been concerns raised
with this application and with previous
applications about
our control over the occupancy of the
caravans and how they might be used
so you'll see in the recommendation
um and if you cross refer that to your
late paper
a condition that we have imposed on
other caravans on the site
and that is included in your
recommendation here
that the caravans are only used as
holiday accommodation
and that that condition is also explicit
that that excludes
being used as somebody's soul or main
residence
and there is a break clause
of one month
in january every year in which there is
to be no occupation
whatsoever there's also
some additional
requirements in that condition
to um
require the operator to keep a register
of people occupying the units and to
make that available to us
on request
the
council's planning enforcement officer
is available to answer any questions
that
members might have about these concerns
relating to the control of occupation
and all the enforcement work member
members will no doubt be aware of the
long history of
enforcement investigation at the site so
if there are any questions i
would defer to nigel to answer those
on the matter of the infrastructure
provision
there has been
recently been a query about the drainage
relating to the site so i'm just going
to move on to the last slide
which i have from the environment agency
the red dots
show the position of
packaged treatment plants around the
complex
package treatment plants are
a means of processing and disposing of
foul waste
and they are an alternative to
maine's sewage connection or septic tank
that sort of thing so you may have heard
the term clargester that's a brand of
package treatment plant it basically
takes foul water treats it um to make
make it safe to then be discharged to a
watercourse
and
that's what these red dots are so these
are the various package treatment plants
which are installed um
there are ongoing communications between
the applicant's agent not their planning
agent their drainage agent they have
engaged binders
you may be familiar with who work
locally on this sort of industry
to
gain all the necessary permits from the
environment agencies so that's ongoing
for
some of the newer development that's
been permitted and the development
developments being proposed
as well as the increased capacity on
some of these in existing installations
and i have information from the agent
the planning agent that
um
the
treatment plants which are not yet
permitted
by the environment agency are being
operated as septic tanks
so they are being emptied
rather than discharging it is the
discharge that requires the permit
rather than the installation
and operation
as as a septic tank and that's covered
covered separately
[Music]
the environment agency have also
comments commented specifically on a
particular concern
relating to the outflow
of two of the two of these package
treatment plants on the highway edge
units one and two that you can see on
the north side of this plan they've
replied to an inquiry to say that
they've inspected that and they're
satisfied with the operation of those
two package treatment plants
so really this plan is just to indicate
to members what exists and what steps
the
applicant has made to
um to manage the operation of the
development in terms of its foul surge
when
when the complex was taken over the
majority of
sewerage was operated
with using
homemade septic tanks made out of old
oil drums as i understand it so those
oil drums have been
replaced with packaged treatment plants
and um
and as i say the conversation is ongoing
with the environment agency to ensure
that those are being um permitted
correctly where
they don't meet the discharge thresholds
that require a permit they operate under
something called the general binding
rules which is very similar to the sort
of permitted development rules for
planning it sort of permitted
development for drainage
so hopefully that gives members a little
bit of comfort
on a matter that had been raised
previously and and had been outstanding
i'm happy to answer any more
any questions that there might be if you
need any more on that
um so just taking you back to
the proposal the additional 18 caravans
at an existing um
complex which makes a significant
contribution to the
tourist economy within the district
as support from our economic development
team
um but as i say does have significant
concerns locally
regarding the impact of the proposal
visually and on the local communities
no consultation responses have raised
any
matters of concern
that would lead us to recommend refusal
um and on the basis of
the benefit that the complex brings to
the authority area in terms of economic
development and tourism traction
the overall recommendation is that we
grant planning permission subject to the
conditions
that are outlined in your papers
thank you chair
thank you
i've got a bunch of questions if i may
start i can't hear you
can everyone else hear me
yes
okay um i've got quite a few questions
please um we haven't heard about the
whole site as a whole so what is the
total number of caravans on this whole
site
we are in the region of 180.
right so there's already 180 there and
are there more that do not are there 180
that are permitted or that what is that
180 what does that actually mean because
i know
yeah 180 is the total number of vans
on the site at the last time there was a
count i i i'm saying that cautiously
because i know that in the last few
months
there has been a complaint regarding the
sighting of touring caravans and the
enforcement officer did investigate that
so not counting touring
static caravans and other permitted
touring units or or other types of
caravans um were counted
as part of the
eia screening element of the application
there's 180 with permission but there
are others that have now appeared that
you're waiting for information on is
that what we're saying touring caravans
that we're waiting for nigel will be
able to tell you whether the tours
are still there or whether they went i
understood they went actually
out of those out of those 180 how many
are occupied in january when they're
supposed to be empty
that is another question that's probably
best put to nigel because every every
caravan has
um that we have granted permission for
well not every caravan but most planning
permissions for the caravans include the
condition outlined similarly as i
explained earlier with the break clause
there are a handful that don't have that
sort of condition on that either became
lawful through the passage of time and
then an ldc or that we granted a long
time ago and we didn't um we didn't
impose any control over but the vast
majority include that condition so
um without wanting to not directly
answer your question
there should on the whole be no
occupation in the month of january but
obviously in the current circumstances
and given the government guidance on
tolerance for enforcement and asking
people to vacate premises because
obviously they're they're not allowed to
move out
um with covered regulations i i would
expect there to be people
in occupation but
could you just confirm what else is on
the site because we haven't been told
what else is happening on the site so
there's how many grand stands how many
fishing lakes how many wedding venues
how many shops what else is at the at
the site already okay so there is um a
big mixture of
tourist attractions including things
like the fishing lakes
how many fishing lakes are there there's
currently
two fishing lakes that are built and
operative
thank you there is an application in for
another
two i think
but it's currently two there is a crazy
golf
course
there is a
foot golf
type course
which is golf that you play with a
football
and with your feet
and there's a shopping arcade there are
a range of shopping units yeah a range
of retail units as well as a cafe
and sort of like an outreach service
post office element to it um
because i was a member we had we i'm
sorry i probably should have declared i
went on a there was a planning
application about five years ago which i
think was called a master plan where we
did a site visit
and there was a wedding venue as well a
wedding function room
yeah that's right there's also the show
ground with the function space there's
some office buildings there's the the
teapot pottery that you may know used to
operate in debenham used to be carter's
ceramics so do all these have planning
permissions they're all they've all been
through the planning process yes yes the
the 2015 permission to which you refer
was a very large um
uh
multi-purpose permission hybrid
permission which dealt to with
regularizing a lot of the unauthorized
development
and dealing with some additional
proposed stuff so at that point
we
got to a position where we were
satisfied that um
i'm not going to say everything was also
authorized because it was an ongoing
discussion in some quarters but on the
whole most of the development was
was regularized and authorized at that
point and then we've had applications
come in since then for on the whole
prospective development there's been a
couple of regularized things such as a
borehole extraction shed
um
things like that okay thank you very
much i'll open it up to others tim can
surpass more yeah
thanks matthew there's three good quick
questions um first of all bronwyn
is it possible to condition
in a planning permission to make sure
that the caravans aren't occupied until
the uh clargester binder systems are put
in
that's the first one and the second
question is probably more appropriate
for nigel
um on the occupancy rules of the um
mobile homes what's the sanction if the
rules are flouted and also how do we
enforce any planting and landscape
escaping scheme is adhered to looked
after and so again what what can the
enforcement team do to make sure it does
actually happen please
okay thank you council possible so the
first question about um controlling
occupation
before the installation of appropriate
drainage infrastructure yes that is
possible
um it's it's a matter of wording of the
condition to to ensure that that happens
before occupation
um occupation of the caravans as holiday
units and not in the break clause
um
as i said nigel will probably give you a
far more detailed account of how the
enforcement team are managing that but
the idea being that that is
um
a stated
control on
use
so that it may not be used for any other
purpose
and we can inspect the register of
um occupants we can also undertake site
visits to actually see
whether there are people living on the
site we're working closely with the
housing team
and licensing on that basis which i'm
sure nigel will give you more detail on
in a moment in terms of landscaping
you'll have seen from the photographs
that some of some landscaping is already
in um
it's it's again a matter of
inspection um it's usual that we require
details to be agreed and then the
subsequent implementation of that in the
following planting season which runs
from october through to march and in a
year
so it would require us to go and see
plants in the ground and then we usually
follow that up with a period of either
five or ten years ongoing maintenance
and replacement of anything that dies
so as part of our
ongoing
commitment to
monitoring the site that would
be expected to be part of an inspection
that the enforcement team would would be
asked to check on if it wasn't something
that somebody like myself was going to
be checking on
as part of a
planning application such as this
can we bring in um
can we bring in the uh do you say nigel
nigel yeah
hi nigel
good good afternoon
could you would you just like to give us
an update where we're at i've just got a
quick question for you we're we're
seeking planning permission for holiday
lodges
and holiday lodges means they're not
your main home so i would have thought
they should all be totally empty now
because under the government guidelines
you're not supposed to be in a holiday
home you're supposed to be your main
residence so i would have thought every
single one should be empty and i'm
confused as to why they're not
um at this particular point in time
because of the coveted restrictions
the government was pretty insistent that
we shouldn't enforce against people that
were
staying in that in their holiday home
for any any given reason
um
what they don't want what we don't want
is people moving around the country
during the lockdown
it's only a central travel that should
be allowed
and so people that are
stuck at stone unbound for whatever
reason
there is a register being kept to find
out how many people are there during
january
that is going to be disclosed to us
at a meeting in february
to better understand the reasons why
people are there
um
about last year a year ago because the
same thing happened a year ago so what
happened last year in general in january
last year
we did an unannounced site monitoring
visit
and went around all of the different
units and didn't find anybody in any of
the units
and that happened the previous year and
i think people were on site the previous
year
so circumstances changed the regulations
were tightened up
and i i personally couldn't find any
breach of the planning condition last
january
do we know how many people because i
understand the local primary school has
people do they have children at the
primary school from the holiday homes
i don't i don't know that okay fine
i did actually ask you about the
sanctions that reverse yes and i would
really like to know that for me please
nigel thank you
yeah what i can say is that the you know
the site is is monitored the planning
condition can be enforced the occupancy
condition can be enforced
and the quickest route to enforcement is
by negotiation
um through the site owner
and people do regularly
change their sort of residential
circumstances
and i have seen people leave the site
when we found out that they have been
living there
and there's other people that
i call it churn in that they
they were there one year and they're no
longer there the next year and i don't
know the reasons for that thank you
so it's mainly it's mainly voluntary and
it's it's by working with the site owner
thank you
councilman
uh thank you chair um uh you uh yourself
asked several of the questions i wanted
to ask about the numbers and the size of
the site uh but something else has
crossed my mind um regarding
uh the past the previous application
where things were sort of regularized i
vaguely remember
there being some talk about a pedestrian
access into the center of stoller mass
ball
as part of that regularization can i ask
if that has happened yet
yes thank you councilman funnily enough
i followed that up with county just last
week they are doing their scoping
exercise in terms of costing apparently
there is some issue to do with
the width of the highway
so they are having to redraft
engineering plans but that and the speed
limit review is also work in hand with
county
thank you
[Music]
i might be able to help i think planning
permission was given for the footway but
the ownership of the land that the
footwear is going on hadn't been
resolved it wasn't in highways ownership
or something like that but but think but
it's obviously uh progressed a bit and
they're doing something about that now
uh it's complicated i think it's the
issue yeah
uh
councillor matheson you were next
thank you yeah moving on to another
subject
can the officers say a little bit about
the
surface water drainage
um i recall some years ago being on a
committee and there was an objector
whose house was actually with several
inches of water in it
um it's that there's a there was other
there's a slide there's a slide with the
blue line on what you can just see the
kink in the blue line it's a long way
from this but the
i think that the issue
were the um
the the you know the overall drainage of
the site now i believe that following
that episode which must have been five
or six years ago or something uh on
another application here um work was
done that's that's the spot now i think
one of those two one of those two
residential properties did flood
and um i think work was done but i i
think as
considerably more development has taken
place i'm bound to ask again if this
site overall is is properly organized
for land uh surface drainage
ron can you help with that
can i try i can't escape
can you hear me
here yeah oh okay sorry i just can't
escape my screen so um i didn't know if
i was muted uh yes so that property
which i was just circling labelled here
is school farmhouse now known as bramley
hedge um
it is that property
um that is involved in the current
concern that's gone to the county
council as the lead local flood
authority and the environment agency as
um discharge permitting authority
and
there is um
there are a number of different
different issues that come into play
this part of the district has got a lot
of agricultural land so when we're in
this sort of time of year when we have
saturated land we have um
exceptionally high rainfall as we had
with the christmas eve flooding event
and as we
we often do at this sort of time of year
it it's what's known as flashy which
means there is a lot of runoff in a
short period of time
and if drainage ditches aren't
maintained
um often they silt up or they get debris
blown in and then they don't operate to
their full capacity that can have an
effect
the environment agency have confirmed to
me that in safaris this site operators
responsibilities for their outflow and
their section of the ditch they've
inspected that fairly recently and
they're satisfied so that's the a11 20
ditch
on these plans he's now not letting me
scroll through
i did have a photo of a ditch along the
southern boundary
so there is a ditch here which
takes
some surface water
runoff and also
um from other properties as well on that
edge
the um
so it's it is a known issue
um and
there are ongoing discussions with the
county councillors lead local flood
authority relating to surface water
drainage
for this scale of development that often
comes forward it's usually something
that's dealt with
through building regulations and things
like that but it is it is a known issue
and we are
addressing it where it's
relevant to the proposal that comes
forward in each case
yes okay thank you i think the ongoing
is is is the worrying part of that
answer um that so it needs needs to be
solved thank you
a counselor there
sorry no my questions have been okay
um no other questions at this point so
we'll move on um thank you very much for
that um we'll now move on to the public
speakers
uh we don't have a representative
uh from the parish
oh sorry um
but counselor susie molly do you want to
read out well you do have a statement
from the parish council so what i'll do
is i'll ask you to read that out prior
to your speech if that's okay
uh and i'll go straight to an objector
uh peter emerson who'd like to speak and
you have three minutes if you could turn
your camera on ron can you take down the
pictures please thank you
sorry i'm trying
welcome um
mr emerson you have three minutes
uh thank you chair um firstly um i'd
like to address the case officers report
as in areas it's somewhat less
misleading
point 4.3 states that uk power networks
have confirmed there is sufficient
capacity within their network to serve
the development this indeed is true
however it does not confirm the network
at stone and barnes has the capacity to
serve its own site which we don't
believe it does and yes most modern
caravans are constructed with electric
heaters and hops however my
investigations suggest the caravans of
stone barns are not of this design
9.2 states this proposal will help the
complex to support an argument for
sustainability
however as stated by the chief planning
officer in a previous application the
site is otherwise unsustainable
therefore on this premise will the
complex be allowed to grow immeasurably
to eventually make itself sustainable
and move on to current issues
due to the unwillingness or inability of
stoneham barnes to manage the site in
accordance with their planning
conditions planning enforcement have
evidenced many occupiers over the last
two years using the caravans as their
solar main residents which we know is
unlawful
this issue has not been addressed by the
applicant
so it can be assumed therefore that this
situation will continue putting further
pressure on enforcement to police the
site
therefore if planning are minded to
grant permission reducing the occupation
terms must be considered for example
eight month occupation first of march to
31st of october this would discourage
the use of solar main residence usage
and reduce planet enforcement's workload
adding another 18 caravans is an
additional 10 stock to the site to make
a total of 200 units that's just the
cast static caravans
this must be considered over development
in the countryside particularly in its
location between two small villages
at present the current utilities cannot
cope with the number of existing
caravans on the site as the site owner
has not invested in upgrades
as you will know utility infrastructure
on a caravan site is the responsibility
of the site owner
any further development will simply
worsen this situation unless significant
investment is made
currently the site has a capacity to be
occupied by over 500 people for 11
months of the year
if this site was viewed as a housing
development the site would need
significant upgrading to attain minimum
standards
the development would also need to
become carbon neutral to comply with
mid-suffolk's climate emergency policy
so is it fair for the basic standards
and policies to be ignored because the
site is governed by a caravan license
and very importantly suffolk fire and
rescue have raised concerns with respect
of emergency water supplies to the
proposed area should there be a fire
should the worst happen granting
permission when the nearest fire hydrant
is nearly one mile from the caravan site
is irresponsible and potentially
life-threatening
in summary this application must be
considered as over development whilst
the spike cannot sustain the numbers of
caravans and occupies without
significant upgrading of the
infrastructure
i therefore recommend that you refuse
this application
thank you
thank you very much
do we have any questions at all at this
stage
nope okay thank you very much for
joining us
now move on to um actually we don't have
the agent and we don't have an apple the
a an app the applicant or the agent uh
or an agent for the applicant aren't
here and they don't wish to speak so
we'll go straight to the ward member
counselor susie morley who's going to
read out the parish statement first and
then speak as the ward member over to
you
thank you chair
so i'll start with the uh parish council
statement which they authorised me to
read out
at the meeting last night
the mppf states that tourist development
in rural locations must respect the
character of the countryside and that
pollution and other adverse effects on
the local environment are minimized
the mid-suffolk district council current
and emerging local plans support the
mppf
and states any proposal must be
appropriate in scale character and
nature of their locality and contribute
to climate change mitigation
this application if successful would
grant permission for a total of 200
static caravans with 11 month occupation
of the units
to put the size of this site into
context
peta which is adjacent to the east has
85 households
and stoner massport directly to the west
145 households
stolen barnes
is not a caravan site in any normal
sense of the term and visually impacts
the surrounding air area
therefore this proposal does not conform
to the nppf nor mid-suffolk local plans
200 static caravans in the countryside
is not appropriate in scale or no or
nature to their locality
in terms of management of the site the
committee sorry is the committee aware
the volume of scrutiny focused on stolen
barnes by planning enforcement
this is because the site owners are
either unwilling or unable to manage the
site in accordance with the current
planning conditions
which include that the caravans cannot
be used as a primary or main residence
they are for holiday purposes only
in addition the planning department the
environment agency and suffolk county
council are all currently investigating
the volume
the u sorry the volume of used water
being discharged from the site into the
local watercourses
a serious complaint has been made by a
householder in a property adjacent to
the site as they are in continual fear
of flooding from the site discharge
this is an ongoing issue and the elderly
householders have now decided they
cannot continue to live with the
constant threat of flooding hanging over
them
because stone and barnes is granted
permission and license under the caravan
development act the responsibility for
utilities on the site falls to the site
owner
the clean water supply has been
regularly disrupted due to demand from
the current occupiers so the supply is
now supplemented by water from a
borehole
because the site is not connected to
main sewage foul waste water has to be
treated by many suspects and waste
treatment plants and this then
discharged into the surrounding ditches
and because the electricity
infrastructure on the site cannot cope
with the demand on the site all cooking
and heating has to use bottled gas
if this development were viewed as a
housing development the site would need
significant upgrading to attain minimum
standards mains water main steward main
sewage electricity supplies surface
water drainage
the development would also need to
become carbon neutral to comply with mid
suffix climate emergency policy
is it fair for basic standards to be
ignored because the site has a caravan
license
these facts highlight the site is
unsustainable it is not fit for purpose
in its current state and crucially
contravenes mid-suffolk's climate
emergency policies
and the current and emergency and
emerging local plans therefore stoner
massable parish council urge you to
refuse this application
thank you
in your own capacity
thank you very much to
just move just some of my windows
this is the latest application to
provide 18 additional holiday lodges on
a remote corner of a grade 3
agricultural field
this proposal is contrary to the
emerging joint local plan and the mppf
because of the visual blight on the
countryside
the application site is outside the
settlement boundary of stoner masspel
in planning policy terms it is
countryside and development in the
countryside is restricted
the planning permission reference 3150
15 which was issued on the 12th of
october 2018
and referred to as the master planning
commission
was hailed as a new chapter in the site
planning history and addressing all the
matters considered outstanding at that
time covering both new development and
the regularization of all unauthorized
development on the site
the various elements covered by the
master planning commission were
carefully assessed and the conditions
attached to it were imposed to minimize
and mitigate the development's impact on
the surrounding area
the location and number of the hology
sorry the location and number of the
holiday lodges were a very important
part part of the planning balance
the number and location of the lodges
were set by the master plan for the
whole site to ensure there is no harmful
over-development at the site
and so that development does not have
unacceptable impacts for example on the
landscape and the living conditions of
those occupying the lodges
the number of that number of lodges was
set at 165
see clause 15 of the section 106
agreement
if this application is approved it will
bring the total number of lodges on this
site to 200
and as the pc have just pointed out the
total number of properties within the
whole village of stoner massport is only
145 properties
these lodges make no contribution to the
financial well-being of my parishes as
neither sill nor council tax are payable
on holiday accommodation
and yet the people already occupying
existing lodges are registered with the
local schools and gp surgeries
placing considerable strain upon the
local facilities rather than
contributing to the sustainability of
stonymaster
notwithstanding the government's advice
to allow occupants to stay during the
normal closed month of january a parish
councillor last night
observed that 40 lodges were occupied
if these were holiday homes then why are
the occupants not wishing to be close to
their main residential address with
access to their own gps
the proposed 18 additional holiday
lodges would lead to the intensification
of the use
and would enable unacceptable over
development on an already unsuitable
site in the countryside outside of the
settlement
boundary whilst the scale of the
proposed development at first glance
appears modest
when considered in the context of the
stone and barn site and with the
community
cumulative impacts it would be a fully
unsustainable development
previous comments regarding salami
slicing tactics must be recognized for
what they are five lodges here 18 lodges
there
that's cumulative creep
with regards to the footpath
previously
identified the width of the verge is not
sufficient for the required footpath
and neither is it within suffolk county
council ownership
discussions are ongoing
the proposed development fails all three
dimensions of the mppf sustainability
test
the economic dimension the the jobs at
stone and barnes have been used over and
over again by the applicant without
evidence
economic benefit from 18 additional
units is minimal
the social dimension is again completely
lacking and the environmental dimension
is negative as the proposal will lead to
further loss of greenfield land and
adverse impact on the environment both
natural and built
thank you chair
so much do we have questions
we have some hands have gone up
sorry okay all right quite see uh
councillor matson the councilman
thank you yes um can
i expect councillor morley would readily
support the parish's view that the all
the cooking and heating
is by gas i wonder whether the officer
can um can confirm that or whether
there's any evidence either way because
i certainly
wanted to
dwell on the issue of electricity supply
when we get into the debate and and
that's that's quite concerning that
we're already
um pressing on the limits of the
electricity side
any more help with that
my understanding is that it's uh cala
gas
can you come can you uh help us with
that
can i come in on that one if i may yeah
um can i just
just remind our members that what we're
dealing with is the use of the land
so ultimately the
design of the caravan and whether that
caravan is all electric with solar
panels on top whether it's gas whether
it's something else
is not really in our remit what we're
dealing with is the use of the land
sustainability
germany if i might have shown i think
what john is saying like why he's quite
right is this is not this is an
application for use not for operational
development is that that is correct
isn't it
it's it's a full it's a full application
so presumably we're entitled to look at
all these three dimensions of
sustainability
one way or another if i may come back
the other issue you have to consider is
that one year there might be a static
caravan of one design and then the
owners of the land decide we'll park a
different uh type of static caravan on
that site or that position uh the
following year and they can keep
changing them as many as the like as
soon as one becomes out of date and uh
you know
disrepair they may come on with a
different type and ultimately
this is the point here it is not
operational land it is it is the use of
the land we are dealing with
well we have to tell that that's a very
that's actually an interesting point of
course they could just change them every
year um okay thank you for that
councillor mansell
uh thank you chair um i just wanted to
raise a point that was brought up by
councillor morley with the uh
enforcement officer that we've got
president present because both she and
the parish council comment and the
objector made the comment that there
were people at the local school and
surgeries uh registered at the local
school and surgeries uh listing this as
their residence
and i'd just like to know what the um
enforcement officer has got to say about
whether that is is the case and whether
it is enforceable that clearly these
people are using it as their main
residence if that is the case bringing
councillor morley then will
bring nigel
yes i i have
not recently
certainly but um in the past have spoken
to individual residents on the site and
they have told me that it is their main
main and only
residence
um whether they are still there now i i
don't know because i haven't been there
for almost a year
okay uh
andrew doyle would you like to just come
in on that
yes when we get um suspicions that
people are living on the site in breach
of the planning condition
uh we what we do is we issue what we
call a planning contravention notice
which you're probably familiar with but
it's a legal letter asking certain
questions
such as where is your main residence
how do you use the property that's done
on barnes can you provide evidence
and just to show where you live
as your main residence and things like
that
and
yes sometimes they come back and it is
pretty clear that their main residence
is at sonoma barns and then we work with
the individual
to
find them somewhere else and they do
tend to move out move after the site
from a planning perspective if we had to
go down the route of an enforcement
notice we would obviously take into
account the circumstances of the
individuals and it might be that we give
people quite a long time to find an
alternative um place to place to stay
however when you work with the site
owner
they work at a much quicker
quicker scale
and can resolve the planning breaches
much quicker
in terms of overall numbers of people
that may be in breach at any one time
there is a lot of churn as i say
on the unit so when i compare the site
register from one year to another i find
that in terms of the units there was 31
changes
from this year to previous years and
that those changes could be new
occupiers of the units
new people in new units units becoming
vacant
then the main residents of the
of the people that stated on the site
register changing
so it's quite a lot of detail that you
have to go into to to actually identify
a breach
but we do do it diligently
and we do find that people are in breach
but we also find that their
circumstances change pretty rapidly
so can i just confirm nigel because
obviously there's lots of talk about
whether the doctor's surgeries are used
when the school is used and they're
applying for 18 holiday lodges so are
people in the holiday lodges using the
local doctor surgeries and the schools
i mean is that actually happening
i do not know i i have i haven't got a
plan relevant to today
um can i if i might just convince you i
think when nigel will correct me if i'm
wrong i'll i'll say good afternoon and
hello to nigel because we in these
strange times we've not managed to meet
each other in the office yet but
um
from
in previous jobs i was a prosecuting a
local government prosecuting solicitor
i've used a school register and evidence
in a benefit fraud case but i
that there are specific powers under the
social security legislation to allow i
i'm not sure that nigel would be able to
go to local schools i want to see or
register um he'll know better than me
but i
i think that's something we might need
to bear in mind
and
so and and i guess i guess ian could you
just clarify how much link should we
link between what is being discussed in
terms of enforcement and what is before
us in the application what is that
relationship
well i think you do have to be mindful
you have an application for um the use
of the land for some uh more um holiday
units and that that is what is before
you you can obviously be mindful of what
is on the site already and its
cumulative effect but i mean broadly
speaking and enforcement of
of
what's gone
what's gone is it is is um yes it's
generally a separate issue
um i think also i will just say and
again nigel won't even need to tell him
this but it is perfectly proper that we
ask him questions about
the what's already on site but there may
be limited limits to what he can say
without breaking
people's personal confidentiality and
data i mean he he doesn't need me to
tell him that but it's just i'm sure
members won't press him to go into
more than just there's so much rumor
around the site it's hard to distinguish
between what is and isn't happening okay
thank you very much councilman did you
want to come up back before i go back to
cancer field well i was just wondering
whether you would permit me to ask a
couple of questions chair not of myself
but of other people
i wonder if the um planning officer
could just
show on the plan
the
where the boreholes are
and what is the proposed mechanism for
getting those to those 18 lodges
because
i i'm understanding that the boreholes
are
right in the center of the site and
those 18 lodges are right out on the far
right of the plan as you look at it and
i'm just wondering
how
how it envisaged the
water will get to those because
otherwise they don't have any access to
water
and my other questions around the
suffolk fire and rescue service where
the nearest fire hydrant is almost is
one and a half k from the proposed
sighting of those 18
caravans and given that they say
that
water will be needed to for any fire
incident
which of the two fishing lakes on the
plan
you envisage the the firemen
having their hoses in
in order to get to those caravans
thank you
oh
thank you councillor morley sorry my
computer is not letting me do two things
at once
um i've shown the sewage treatment plant
layout plan
which i think is hopefully the most
useful to show where the boreholes
are
so there is an abstraction point in the
area of the fishing lakes
um and there is another
one hang on where are we
come in here there's another one in
on this side of the site
as well
neither of those are anywhere near the
proposed 18 which is off off the right
of that picture
yeah the proposed 18
is just off the right hand side the
nearest abstraction is
in this area here
so i'll be satisfied that the fire hoses
will reach from there to those 18 vans
caravans
i would have to go back to
give you the verbatim response that we
had from suffolk fire and rescue
previously but my understanding is that
that where there are no hydrants in
place
um open bodies of water as there are in
this complex
are satisfactory um john might be able
to help me out with this there is a
distance
limit for open bodies of water for fire
fighting i i will need to go away and
find that out to give you a definitive
and let's jump those
[Music]
um
i know the the fire engine one which is
45 meters but i don't know the open body
of water one if i'm fairly honest i
would have to do that up myself so
we could come back to you with that if
that would be helpful in a moment we'll
just find that if we can okay
okay we'll go on to john
field councillor field
thank you um a couple of questions
really to make sure i'm getting this
right
the officer was talking about sort of 31
changes
last year in um
and the con in the
people who are accommodated um there's
182 lodges so that would imply that an
awful lot of the
residents are there
pretty permanently yeah it's uh
sort of stunning new town isn't it
rather than anything else um uh
going on to the matter of monitoring and
bearing in mind there's no council tax
or anything paid on these houses um you
you mentioned did you diligently monitor
the uh the the residents and and um try
and ensure that they're complying with
this uh rule of um
that this is a holiday accommodation
basically i wonder what level of
resource we're actually deploying at the
moment on that activity because it might
give us some
feel for
how big or how exaggerated this issue is
thank you should i should ask that after
that chair yes please
i'm sorry in terms of the 31 changes i'm
actually referring to the site register
the previous permissions that have been
granted also
require the the owner to maintain a site
register
and when we ask for it
um they're obliged to give it to us and
we've asked for it for six six times
since 2018
which is a lot a lot a lot of requests
actually
so we've got very good information about
what's actually happening on the site
that site register tells us
the name of the unit which is usually a
number the name of the person that is
owning the unit or occupying the unit
and their primary residence as well
so that's the sort of information that
we get
so when i talk about 31 changes i'm just
indicating that there's quite a sort of
fluid situation with individuals
moving in and out of the site or between
units or their main home address
changing
but we only know that because we've we
asked for the site register that's
reasonable but it just sounds as though
if it's holiday accommodation you might
expect the uh
whole 182 to be changing
once a month or something once every
couple of months which will be a much
bigger volume than you're indicating um
the actual
a large proportion of the units are
actually owner occupied
so they're owned by individuals and then
they have a license to be on the land
um a number of the units are rental
units so they're owned by sort of
stomatal and bonds the company
and they're rented out and so that their
occupant their occupancy would change
rapidly yes
um
but it's the it's the only occupied ones
that we've we focus on in terms of
finding out their primary residence
thank you counselor
um thanks matthew i don't know whether
susie wouldn't have the answer this or
perhaps one of the um planning team have
we any idea what the sort of occupancy
rates of the existing um lodges are
because that's a key economic driver for
any successful tourism business
um so i'm really wondering well how
necessary is this and it may not be a
material consideration it would help
shape the debate
may answer that chair
yes please do
thank you we don't have a lot of
specific detail on this but but um we do
have some information that suggests that
um
a
branded national holiday company
um have some interest in
taking over some of the units if
permissions are granted
um without any restriction other than
the one-month break clause that's
probably as much as i can say without
right oh that's interesting
thank you bro thank you
can i just ask the bit of my question
that didn't get answered was the bit
that sort of says
does this use um
a couple of hours of uh enforcement time
a month or is it a full-time officer all
year today okay two limits
yep
it's um
if i answer that one because i focus on
stone and barnes as one one of my roles
it's probably
three or four hours a week
thank you and and has it been higher
than that in the past or lower
over the last uh since since the master
plan was issued
i i don't have the answer to that i'm a
recent employee yeah okay thank you
okay i don't have any other hands up and
do we just have any uh the question that
was asked earlier do we have any
anything more to add
if i may um i can't find anything
specific but under obviously building
regulations and the file regulations the
the standard requirement uh for a fire
engine is 45 minutes 45 meters and
that's taking an average of hose length
and allowing a little bit of flexibility
so ultimately when we look at how a fire
truck can get to a site uh distribute
the hoses and get to the all elements of
a dwelling
it's a 45 a 40 i keep saying that 45
meter
distance yeah i don't think it would be
a a wrong assumption to make that if you
take the hose length from a open water
source
to the site and the caravan in this
instance to get around that caravan that
45 meters given hose lamps available for
fire apparatus uh you know it's going to
be similar to that
and that expectation is probably needs
to be similar in that vein i don't think
we can give you a specific answer
there's a different uh regulation out
there but we've not been able to find it
in the short time we've had to look so
there might be but
otherwise it's not unreasonable
assumption it should be something
similar to 45
but the distance from the lodges to the
fishing lake is greater than 45 meters
i would ask prominence to confirm that
or not but
that would be a
a point that we may need to look into
further
if necessary
okay
can you confirm either way bro
sorry i'm just trying to look through
the guidance on um
water for firefighting
which speaks about the use of open body
water but it doesn't actually specify a
distance from that open body so what i'm
now trying to do is find the specific
comment that we had from
fire and rescue because i'm not sure if
they specified a distance or if they
just said that they were satisfied that
there was provision on site that was
accessible um
but if you have a look at the layout
plan
do they not also recommend sprinkler
systems was that what i read when i went
through
but obviously this is advisory guidance
not
a matter of objection from the fire and
rescue service
they also usually say that you have to
comply with building rigs and things
like that
it's on page 403 of the plan yeah it is
four three four three four four
okay um right members well that's all
the questions we've got so it's now
really over to us to discuss debate
and to come to a conclusion
um
on this one um
i don't know who wants to go i mean i
can easily go first but i don't want to
lead the committee really counselor
stringer
yeah i
i i don't mind throwing my hat in the
ring uh don't [ __ ] declare an
interest about this uh for those of you
that don't know i organize uh about 25
volunteers in the membership area as a
covid response squad
and we regularly get calls
to deliver prescriptions to the existing
lodges
and the addresses are clearly marked on
the prescriptions so they are registered
with our gps and uh i've delivered a few
myself and i've asked the people where
do you live and they say here
so
they didn't look like they were on
holiday to me uh anyway that that that's
another side i think what we also need
to do while we're sort of
i'll digress a bit and then i'll come
back to the substantial planning issues
if you actually look on their website
the predominant these are predominantly
being sold for between 40 and 70 000
quid a pop
and the website's really helpful it
tells you that if you were to purchase
one of these luxury cabins that they
would be available for you quote all
year round
so uh that seems to be it's like odds
with the planning permission for them
they also say they're that glorious
beaches are just a stone's throw away
so this there's a slight uh you know
manufacturing of of geography as well
getting back to uh uh planning policy
issues uh uh it's very helpful to see
how many package plants are now on a map
we couldn't get the answer to that last
time
uh although the guidance says that you
shouldn't put any more than nine
properties into one package plant
there's still a way to go here and i
would actually like to see how those
package plants
discharge into the the water courses
because we're getting quite a network of
these now
also happy to hear again that a branded
holiday company is is looking to invest
here we were told that last time we
approved the last stop uh and we haven't
seen them branded yet
uh
frankly i i
will not be voting in favor of this i
think the intrusion into what is
completely open countryside is basically
not justified for the limited amount of
economic benefit that we will get
uh and that's basically simple what we
will probably get is a bit of business
rates some minor uh possible injection
into the local economy but most of the
spend i would imagine will happen on
site because of all the facilities that
are there so so so frankly i i think the
intrusion into open countryside for this
particular development is unwarranted
for the amount of economic benefit we'll
gain so i will not be voting in favor of
this application thank you chair
thank you i've got i'll i'll council
mayor if you want to go next and i'd
like to come in before just uh with some
thoughts on
because i yeah after you you go first
thanks um
for me the question is is this site
overdeveloped
major planning
um review in 2015 everything was
regularized fantastic and further
developments in
2020
parish council think it's over developed
the ward member think it's over
developed
and yet the agent isn't here there's no
applicant they haven't put their case
so i think what we've got here is
classic
planning creep we've now got to the
point where enforcement officers are
regularly involved on site what does
that suggest to me it does suggest that
this site is becoming
too big uncontrollable not properly
managed so i tend to fall uh on the side
of the parish council and the ward
member
this site is over developed um and i
think we should reject this application
on that basis and i will be voting
against
well thank you
thank you can i um can i just give some
thoughts so
um
this site clearly is that there isn't
good design in what's been proposed
and it's not going to create a better
place for people to live uh it's not
going to create
any benefit for the whole community and
it's certainly not going to benefit
the character of the area or the open
landscape and the quality of the area or
to the residents of nearby villages
the site is we've seen the pictures it's
really visible from the highway
you can see it
and
the public actually attends stoneham
barnes and they can see it
so
i think that has significant impact on
the environment
as well
the visibility of the lodges are all
very uniform they're all very same
uh and actually they're equally spaced
out it's a linear sort of design
and it just it that goes into open
countryside and to me that's a classic
clash of two designs coming trying to
come together which i don't think is
good design
the
lodges i think look stark they look
man-made
and they are not a positive addition to
the open and rural countryside and the
character of the countryside in that
part of suffolk and the our part of
suffolk i guess it's the majority of the
part of mid suffolk
so i also have concerns that um where is
the plan
it's exactly as counselor mayor said
it's creep
so you know we had five before we did a
master plan which took officers years to
get together coming together to find a
master plan for stone and barnes which
was the parish council got involved
everyone got involved and i remember
going on that mini bus having a tour
this is the master plan the master plan
has been done and now we're getting
creep again we're getting the old one
the odd one the odd one i would really
like officers to actually go away and
work with the applicant so there is a
long-term plan and real clarity about
what is coming and what the future holds
and that is it rather than this creep of
having another five another 18
another fishing lake and it just goes on
and on and i don't think that is a
realistic way in which to uh be fair to
the residents of the neighboring
communities
um so
i am minded to refuse but i also kind of
think we should we take a minded to
refuse then ask officers to go away to
review the landscape position
uh to review what the long-term plans
are to look at the landscape character
and appearance uh regarding to our
policies there are a few policies in
which that i believes it clashes with my
worry is if we just refuse it
by if we actually go minded to refuse
are we then giving us actually an
opportunity to make some progress rather
than just sort of shutting down the
gates and and we're we sort of we just
sit and wait for another one to come in
should we actually have have we got
better opportunity than just refusing it
um anyway i'll keep going to others
councillor mansell
uh thank you chair um i i am i
agree with with much of what my fellow
councillors have been saying
um although um you yourself uh council
hicks was going on about design
but this really is an application for
change of use of land and the design of
a mobile home looks like a mobile home
and i i'm not sure quite what a change
of use application can do about what a
mobile home looks like
um however i i don't think i can support
this uh on the ground it is an intrusion
into the countryside
and i can't really see
what the benefits are there are clearly
some dis benefits in that um despite all
of the um so-called regularization of
this site
there are clearly strains on the local
infrastructure and we get nothing in in
return to help alleviate those strains
on the local infrastructure because this
is only a temporary accommodation
holiday park
um and
you know also we've got we've we've just
heard about our own officer
time that is spent dealing with this
site that that is a that is a cost and
the economic benefit of having 18 more
holiday homes
on this site uh does not outweigh those
dis benefits in my mind we've got we've
got lots of things that we don't like
about it and and very little positive
outcome um from from this application so
i don't think i can support it um
thank you
thanks very much
councillor muller
thank you chair i totally sort of agree
with all the comments that fellow
members have made and in my opinion i do
agree with them and i also think the
idea you've put forward um counselor
hicks is also quite a valid um situation
for this however as it stands i will not
be supporting this application thank you
thanks um john uh sorry um uh
does braun or john does someone just
want to comment on is there any benefit
to uh being a minded to refuse with
asking for a sort of master plan to be
put together the reasons i gave or is
that just a red herring is there any
added benefit to that over just refusing
it because i can see we're all talking
about the same thing
okay if i may come in there chair and
possibly assist um obviously i'm
listening to everything that everybody
has said but
there is advantages to a minded uh to
well you can defer or minded to refuse
and then and ask us to defer and come
back um i think we there are some
outstanding issues in respect of
landscape
harm that we would perhaps request that
we are given the opportunities officers
to go away and consider um and take
further advice on and i think that would
be
useful i don't think we've actually got
that uh to hand in respect to we often
use play services and others um to
specifically report on the landscape
impact of this use now we might not have
the design of the lodges but the use has
to integrate with the landscape and the
countryside and the character of the
area and if we are saying this is
potentially intrusive to the landscape
area sorry landscape a character an
appearance um you know then we do have
policies that we can look at but we you
know we would want to have the support
of a independent landscape um
advisory uh consultant that would
support us if we had to then carry that
through to appeal so it might be prudent
for us to go away uh as a deferral uh in
order to
find that information but i will lead
you to your policies gp1 and
rt17 of your local plan but equally and
possibly just as importantly i you know
you do pick up on the various paragraphs
of good design that do apply to
character and landscaping
within the mppf
we may not know what type of caravan
this is but we certainly need to work
out if it's going to integrate within
the uh the area
i
would
very
roughly just mention
that i am i was curiously looking at the
um sort of advisory guidance on the
environmental impact assessment and we
are just below that threshold and it
might be another reason there that we
say look we really do need to be very
careful here in respect of the the
landscape harm of the development and we
may be needing to look at the advice on
that as well
does that help yes so
so in terms of the master plan sorry i
didn't really answer that question
apologies um so in terms of the master
plan well we keep calling it a master
plan but
essentially
it was it's it was an application to
regularize the development that it would
dealt with but what you've got to deal
with here is this application on and i i
apologize for the frustration this
statement may cause but you have to deal
with this application on its merits and
the planning harm of this application
and that is why
you know deferring for us to
put together the
and check on the landscape harm to
ensure that we've got a very robust
position to be in would be where minded
to refuse and allowing us to defer
uh would be an advantage for the council
in its consideration i can't just ask if
there was a long-term plan for stone and
barnes wouldn't that therefore allow us
to consider what safeguarding there
needs to be for the landscape character
and the quality of the area and its
relationship with the neighboring
villages
we can try to encourage that and i i
would heartily recommend it to um the
landowner and or applicant um but we you
know we can't force or impose it
and we we can certainly have that
discussion but we have to deal with this
application as presented
okay thank you very much
[Music]
okay
uh well
i um i won't propose yet i'll leave
others too but yeah okay who's next up
is now i've still got councillor mayor
then councillor matheson then councillor
passport council of field in that order
sorry legacy hand
hey from matheson
fry thank you well i i must say i i find
the the narrow
um the narrow definition that we were
offered that we were just talking about
the use of the land
um i must say i find that frustratingly
narrow
um the reality is that the intention is
to put
put mobile homes on this land and to
occupy them for
11 11 months of the year etc
with the with all the concomitant
utility requirements etcetera that we've
been discussing so i i do find that
difficult and i think the interestingly
the the chair actually strayed into into
the realms of of um
this you know a place to live um and of
course that's exactly what we're
supposed to be not discussing a place to
live uh supposed to be a holiday home
um
and
i just
was going through the the mppf just to
see
what there was and there was very little
to be to be said
um
so far but i've reached paragraph 151
and this says that we should be helping
to increase through our decisions even
this one help increase the use and
supply of renewable and low carbon
energy and heat and then there's three
some paragraph sub paragraphs of that
about um you know the
strategy strategy for energy from these
sources and so on and so on which you
you can imagine you don't need to read
them all really um
and and
this there is nothing like that that one
can see in sight
other than the statement from the parish
council that all the um
all the cooking and heating has to be
gas
because of the strains on the
electricity supply already and um
so unless that electricity supply is
magically coming from renewable sources
on site and i haven't heard any mention
of that either um we're not going in
that direction
as with the site and then we're not
going in that direction
by actually
having another 18 lodges on there so i i
i mean i i agree with many things that
other members have said
and um
i think
i yeah there are limited difficulties
there are limited reasons that we can
cite
for for refusing or deferring but but
they are there and the common sense is
something we perhaps we should deploy
i'm very happy to put a proposal forward
unless someone else wants to go with a
proposal because i think we've all said
the same thing over and over get on with
it
yeah
are you happy john do you want to come
in first
i'd be happy to propose yeah so can i
propose that we put forward a minded to
refuse yes and defer for officers
actually to get advice
and
based on what john just said i think
that we need the chief planning officer
to review and review
uh and look at the risk in terms of the
reasons for refusal around the impact of
the development on the landscape the
character and appearance of the proposal
uh and john mentioned i wrote down here
you mentioned gp1 and rt17 of the local
plan but also the design and layout and
the
possibly what opportunities are actually
to improve the character and quality of
the area
uh john do you want to come in i mean am
i barking down the wrong going down the
wrong
i would never avenue i can't comment on
that um no but the thing is what we
don't want to do is to go down a route
which is clearly at an appeal would put
us in a difficult position so um
how do we sit where would you take us
can i well i have got some words here
that i've been jotting around and it
might be of help if i try to kind of
express it this way
um so ultimately you know
you're suggesting to me that the
committee are minded to refuse the
application on the ground so the
development would fail to represent good
design and not create a better place in
which to live and work for the whole
community of the area and would not
improve the character and quality of the
area and i think we're putting this to
context the site is clearly visible from
public advantage points uh and moreover
obviously this is a public site you know
they are rigidly able to visit stolen
barns and experience the locality
so what we've got here is we've
mentioned the lodges are in design
likely to be quite
formal even if there are different types
the layout is linear and it extends into
the open country side
um
and i think in terms of its man-made
edition whatever the form that might
take in in the actual type of uh
caravans its addition to the open and
rural countryside does represent
potential harm
to the character and appearance of the
landscape so you're suggesting therefore
it might be contrary to policies uh gp1
and rt17
as well as i suggest paragraphs one two
four one two seven and one sixty of the
nppf
and you're
going to ask us on the basis being
minded to approve refuse
to review and risk assess these reasons
for refusal
and concurrently i suggest seek
independent landscape and design advice
on the
issue of visual impact and harm on the
landscape character
and
i would perhaps add this in which is the
extent to which the design and layout
takes the opportunities available for
improving the character and quality of
the area and the way it functions and
that's with a reference to 1 2 7 and 130
of the mppf
okay i'm very happy to propose on that
grounds
john did you want to come in
john field sorry
there's more than one john is the
problem yes sir
the uh i'm quite happy to second that
for you um
no no i think you've covered most of the
things i had written down here you know
the landscape arm um
i also thought it
the the developments getting to the size
that it begins to dominate the local
communities as we've heard
so we should be extremely careful of
that
i'm inclined to see
the holiday use as um
largely make believe at the moment at
least a fair percentage uh it would be
for the applicant to prove that that's
not so at the moment we seem to just run
around in circles um
uh i'm in favor of uh what if you like a
new
uh master plan but we would have to have
an understanding a clear understanding
that that
is a master plan it's not a master plan
for this week and until we you know push
it another
number of lodges further so i i'm sure
that will be covered in what's said so
on that basis i'll try to get one second
i'm i'm thinking of moving us on because
i think everyone unless we've got a new
point um i think we've got a proposer
and a seconder yeah i i mean
yeah tim you're next week
yeah and just be very careful i used to
be involved in um
economic developments many years ago
don't forget holiday lodges do not
necessarily equate to mobile homes so
what we really do need to do is make
sure when we come up with this we want
high quality tourism jobs and high
quality places so i would have voted
against this as it said so i should
certainly support you there but i would
just add that to the for the officers
when they look at this we do need these
high quality jobs but holiday lodges
don't have to be mobile homes and there
are many designs very high quality which
would attract um high wealth customers
and of course this application i know
we're talking about land use very
important to bear that in mind otherwise
be careful for what you wish for and i
think we're all on the same page there
but that is a very important point to
look at don't forget please thank you
thank you very much
uh councilman did you yeah
seems to be a confusion about whether we
can or cannot control what they what
they put on there so long as it roughly
fits within the definition of caravans
or something so i i think that's you
know mr pack she did actually use the
words um place to live and work which
again i'd say is is contrary to the this
is sort of narrow use of land definition
but the other thing is living and work
for the whole community that could be
the neighboring villages need to be need
to be careful or that one could get shot
shot down but the only other the only
other point was whether we wanted to
point the officers and the applicant to
the issue of energy supply
john pemg is that something we can tie
into this or not
um
i'm slightly
resisting that on the basis of the
consistency of previous decisions
immediately adjacent to this site um and
also
the
i i recognize obviously councillor
madison did point out paragraph 151
although unfortunately that refers to
plans not decision making um
and we
we can certainly you know we're going to
go away and we can ask the question but
i i'm i'm
not sure where to take that much further
i'd have to have further advice on that
but um it'd be the first time we've done
something like that for
caravans
into my knowledge
okay
and then well right when i say caravans
i'll say caravan to the definition of
the caravan act and of course you know
even a lodge which can be transported in
two parts is a defined caravan so uh
when i do say caravans i'm not always
talking about the very cute little uh
white uh van that we can pull behind our
cars i am talking about the
the definition of caravan as the act
states quite so
okay so i think it's been proposed by
myself and seconded by council field as
per the recommendations for minded to
refuse and deferral for advice
as per the reasons read out by uh john
pateman g
um i don't think we need to go through
them again i think josh read them out
clearly um
on that basis we'd like to go to an
electronic vote please
oh god she was his bloody thing
tim tim we can hear everything sorry
sorry
problem
do you apologize thank you chair i'm
warning you
um i just know i've got all of the
wording in unfortunately it's cut off
the last part of that's fine you can see
it what um mr pikmin jesus said which is
the last paragraph but as long as
members are content that they are aware
of what
um mr patemanji has said
in full um yeah it's just the last
couple of points i think there's a word
limit on here if anyone is not content
that they're fully aware of the what
we're voting on please raise your hand
otherwise we'll proceed
okay we're happy to proceed okay chair
so i will now open the vote this will
appear on modern.gov under the plus sign
in the agenda and it will turn blue you
may have to scroll down the page to see
the blue line for this vote
okay and just to be clear we're voting
on what's before us if you're four four
minded to refuse rather than for the
original proposal
so it's four minded to refuse
oh got it
well
that's wrong
oh sorry cancer have you
sorry i'm i'm supporting the proposal
sorry
okay um i do have the option here to
rerun it so i will just open it again um
so that we can take that one again
apologies for everyone i'm afraid so
chair uh voting for the recommended
right got it
right i'll open it up again apologies
chair so then members can
so everyone needs to vote one more time
please yes apologies
it's not come up on us oh there it is
okay
[Music]
okay
thank you chair i can confirm that that
was a
unanimous vote for the proposal
thank you very much okay we're going to
move on to the last item for today
uh which is a gender item
uh dc 2004
630 and over to alex scott to present
well thank you chairman
just
present the
presentation
so you can all see
that all right so this is a um
an application under section 73 of the
town and country planning act um it's
it's variation to an existing planning
permission
um at uh
land west of uh watersfield road walsh
from willows uh the proposal is for 60
dwellings
and the proposed variation would
increase
the number of affordable dwellings
previously approved
by 10 so we are going from 21
uh affordable dwellings as previously
approved to 31 as
currently proposed and for clarity there
is no
increase in the uh
in the amount of uh and the total amount
of dwellings uh proposed that would
remain at 60
and
the increase of affordable dwellings
would be at the expense of market
dwellings so uh 10 more affordable
dwellings 10 less market dwellings
proposed
there are also some
some some minor revisions to the layout
proposed in association with that
the the design and types of dwellings
will not change
uh however there is the removal of a
twin garage between plots 29 and 30.
the provision
of garden sheds for a number of
dwellings uh
27 i count and
some minor amendments to um to gates
walls fences boundary treatments so i'll
just run you through the presentation
this uh first slide shows the location
of welsh on the willows within the
district uh for the avoidance of doubt
and the general location of the uh
site uh within the parish
uh here is a wide scale aerial map of
the site
and a closer view for you
this next slide shows the planning
constraints um we're outside the
settlement boundary of the village
site here and this dotted lines are
public rights of way
the uh site location plan as submitted
with the
the application
and this is the layout as currently
proposed and the dwelling types are
color-coded down
and down the bottom right there as
you're looking at it
and just for um for information um 1b 2p
uh that indicates one bed two person um
and uh there are flat semi detached
dwellings and the ones uh
not referenced are detached dwellings
just for your information there and we
have the
on the left hand side of your screen is
what was previously approved as part of
the previous reserve matters approval
and this is what is now currently
proposed uh a case of spot the
difference but um
uh when you're looking at uh really the
removal of this uh
this double garage here and the addition
of uh garden sheds uh
those are the main uh the main changes
proposed
and this is a breakdown of the uh the
housing and types proposed so we have 29
market dwellings 27
affordable houses and four affordable
flats so that's 31 affordable dwellings
in total
this is a 3d
street scene
layout
for your information
and the front elevations as proposed the
proposed market dwellings and associated
garages at the bottom
and the proposed affordable dwellings
with the
flats building
down in the bottom left hand
corner uh this is the um
waste management strategy essentially
where the uh the bins will be stored and
presented on bin days
uh boundary treatments uh plan um so red
indicating walls and uh green
fences
this is the parking plan um
be pleased to know no triple parking is
proposed and
um a
minor breakdown here which is we think
in accordance with uh
advisory parking standards and um
excuse me um suffolk highways have
raised no objection
and
materials plan
as proposed which is um relatively the
same as what has previously been
approved as is the phasing plan
and as is the landscape strategy
the
uh surface water attenuation basin um
child's play area and um
increased uh landscape buffering um
ecology benefits there as previously uh
proposed and approved so uh no
significant changes there
uh on to some uh photographs for you um
i would stress that these uh of some age
the development as previously approved
um
has commenced uh so i wasn't able to get
down there and get any um
new photographs for various reasons but
uh
hopefully this gives uh an idea of the
site and how it did sit uh
until relatively uh
recently some views across the field
and those are the dwellings uh friending
watersfield road
and
lastly the near neighbour
okay that concludes the presentation uh
as per your papers officer
recommendation for approval thank you
chairman
thank you very much do we have any
questions at all at this point
yes councilman
thank you chair um i'd just like to ask
just for a bit of clarity
um i spotted the garage removal on the
plan
um and maybe i've missed the plot
somewhere else but can you confirm that
there's no actual change to the style of
the houses they are literally going to
be built exactly the same as they were
before but converted into but being sold
as affordable housing rather than market
dwellings and do we actually have a
layout showing
which ones are swapping from being
market houses to affordable houses
[Music]
uh right yes thank you councilman i mean
uh first of all yes i just confirmed
that um the
proposed uh dwelling styles um will not
change um it's simply um the market
houses before will
transfer to uh to affordables and that's
uh that's all is proposed so no no
change to changes to the table styles of
dwellings just the uh
whether they would be affordable or um
or open market as as per where exactly
they are on the plan um
yes it's a little bit difficult to it's
a show and i haven't considered that
question i'm afraid but um
if i can just go back i mean are they
are they sort of dotted about the site
or are they just like one row
um
and and and as well as clarifying that
they're the same
style of housing they will be built to
the same standard and specification
well certainly the same standard and
specification i can definitely confirm
that as to where they were i'll try and
go back to the comparative layout
yes you can see that
okay
um
yes
let me just see here so uh so the
affordable
homes would be uh h7
hey which would be the uh
the purple homes i think there might be
a bit of um
yes i do apologize i should have um
anticipated this a little bit more um
[Music]
i may have to go away and get to get
further information if that's essential
apologies
i don't i don't know that it was
essentially it was just interest really
and the fact that
because they've all got different
specification numbers that was what
baffled me i was thinking there's
obviously something about this whatever
it was h
um
you know h789a
is being being built as an affordable
house and none of the market houses have
got that that number
um and and that was why i was asking
really that you know that are there are
they just the same houses and they're
just being turned into being affordable
and and i presume they are dotted about
the site can i
come in i won't have that
so in terms of the description of the
development um i've got here that it's
from market to affordable to plots 27 28
29 30 that's one group then we have 37
38
and then we have 54 55 56 and 57 so um
the answer is they're not all together
but they're probably in three clusters
uh 27 through to 30
um 37
and 38 and then we have 54 through to
57. i don't know if that's identifiable
on a plan at the
on these slides because i don't think
that that information is going to be
very clear is it alex are you able to
identify those clusters
very difficult on the three but uh yes
thank you for that and um yeah just
looking at the report yes um it would
indicate there would be three clusters i
would need to produce a a plan to make
that clearer apologies that i didn't do
that let me
while this discussion continues if you
if
if you're okay members i will just very
quickly see if i can just bring up the
original plan on the file itself and if
i can zoom in to look at those plots i
can then hopefully share that with you
if we want to continue i can come back
to you on that point
okay uh councillor field then cancer
maths
yes just a quick
quick question uh
surprised to see a change in that
direction so i was questioning uh
presumably that reduces the amount of
sill we collect on the um
development does that have any impact at
all on say educational allowances that
come off or are they determined by 106
or through the sale mechanism
so is there any
impact in that direction that we don't
expect
uh well from yeah from my understanding
i mean it wouldn't be the section 106
all we're asking is um for the
affordable dwellings to be secured by
the section 106 plus uh contribution for
uh secondary school uh travel um so any
uh
any primary uh school contributions um
for the village would be secured
by way of sell
um
and
as as we have an increase in affordable
housing um
yes yes the contributions may be less
because of that
presumably provided from elsewhere so
okay
okay
um if i may just come in on that point i
can just just show you where these
affordable units are if i i'm going to
attempt the probably impossible here and
try and share a different part of a
screen that i don't normally share but
hopefully this works
uh would that come up has that come up
to everybody yeah
okay so plots 27 is this plot here you
can see my cursor i'm hoping you can
through to plot 30 so it's that cluster
of four just there are changing from
market to affordable we then have 38 and
37 which is this semi-detached unit here
and we then have
uh what was it it was 54
54 which is that one through
257 so it's those
two sets of 70s there so in effect they
are quite spread out because you've
actually got
a new group per uh road as you go across
the site
does that help
yep
great thank you
councillor matheson yeah thank you i
think the the as a long advocate of
pepper potting social housing across
sites i think three clusters that that
must um must fit into any guidance
really well what i was just slightly
puzzled about as we haven't seen a waste
management strategy plan
before that i recall but what i do
recall and i can't find it on this
application now is is a note about the
the um
the bins being brought to collection
points on the main road
now that might have actually been the
the um
the whitten application that i read that
on
but um my right and understanding then
that the
the end of the you need a magnifying
glass which i'll just
use it so really what we're saying is
those green lines
are are the distance that the individual
householders have to move their bins
in other words most of them are just
brought into the front of the house and
then the flats is a little more
complicated as one
might expect
um
and so so the
the vehicle is going to go right through
the site in fact is that my
understanding right
okay we'll just get that answer for you
john then when we move on to the ward
member okay can you answer that please
alex
um yes yes i said um yeah that's the
general um the general principle really
the
lines yes
and and they can get around yes we have
a sweater path on that analysis and
everything like that so okay yeah thank
you okay thank you okay so we don't have
any public speakers uh we don't have
anyone from the parish council uh or uh
the applicant or agent or supporter or
objective so we'll go straight to the
ward member councillor richard mayer
over to you
thanks chair um you'll press be pleased
to know that i've got very little to say
other than uh the parish council are
supportive of this change
that's it
any questions for the ward member
no okay so we'll now move up to debate
uh and over to members to discuss
councillor muller first off
thank you very much chair i really
welcome this change actually to increase
from 35 percent to 51.67
in affordable housing i don't know i've
ever come across this before
the the parish council in favor of the
war members in favor it so would i just
recommend approval for this application
change thank you chair
much counselor
uh thank you chair um i i too was going
to say something pretty similar to to
counselor mueller
i i think this is a very welcome
surprise actually to find that a
developer wants to put more affordables
in i don't quite understand um maybe the
reasons behind it um
that it might be concerns about uh less
sill payments but if the parish council
and the ward member are in favor of it
uh the loss of the one garage doesn't
seem to have resulted in loss of parking
spaces it's just there'll be um they
won't have a garage they'll have a shed
the inclusion of more garden sheds for
bicycle storage sounds like a positive
move so i can't really see any reason
not to um approve this application so
i'm happy to second councillor muller's
uh proposal thank you very much
councillor passmore
that's what i was going to say so i'm
very happy to support this i think it's
a very good welcome development thank
you and councillor stringer
yeah
thank you chair yeah the the the
inclusion of more affordables is
actually probably a sign of the market
for market forces uh because of yeah
we're probably entering some slightly
rockier times economically and of course
that that that money tends to be more
ring fenced and copper bombed so uh this
is hardly any sprites although it is
welcome
and probably more in line with what
communities need uh i
outline stage i voted against this one
because this particular design they'd
orientated most of the rooms so they
couldn't benefit from most of the solar
gain i won't be that churlish a second
time round i will be voting in favor but
just mindful we need to get far better
at orientation of buildings thank you
thank you very much okay we have no one
else that wishes to speak and it has
been proposed
by councillor muller and seconded by
councillor mansell as per the
recommendations as laid out in our
papers on page one sorry four two one
and four two two can we please go to an
electronic vote
so thank you members the vote is in the
usual place
in the modern.gov app so if you press
plus on
the
agenda
and then the vote will be highlighted in
light blue
and just to know obviously for anyone
watching that counselor mayor cannot
take part as he is the ward member
that's in line with mid-suffolk protocol
thank you very much
just waiting on one vote from councillor
field
you're okay there john
yes it's there i'd foolishly closed
modern.gov that that's come through
okay and the results of the voter so
that's unanimously approved chair
okay thank you very much the only other
gender item is do we have any site
inspection requests that need to be
reported to this committee no chair
okay well thanks everyone and we've
covered a lot of ground today and it's
been a long day and thank you for
dealing with all the technical
interruptions at the beginning
uh close the meeting at 15 42 and enjoy
the rest of your afternoon thanks
everyone thank you thank you
thank you for clarifying before we vote
uh
giving us clarity on what we're voting
on that that's that's been a sort of ban
a bone of contention in other meetings
recently and that's really helpful for
you to clarify that and thank you for
doing it
indeed pleasure council stringer have a
good afternoon here we go